reprenons les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par une table ronde
qui est consacrée cet après-midi aux
enjeux de la rénovation du parc des
logements sociaux nous recevons ainsi
des représentants de trois organismes
tout d'abord madame Emmanuel Coste dans
ses fonctions non pas d'anciennes
ministres puisque nous l'avons déjà
auditionné dans ce cadre-là mais de
présidente de l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat qui rassemble le mouvement Hlm
madame ankermialo qui est directrice
générale de l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine créée il y a 20 ans
pour la restructuration la
réhabilitation et la requalification des
quartiers prioritaires et monsieur Simon
molinsa
molsa
molesa pardon directeur du patrimoine de
la régie immobilière de la ville de
Paris qui est un acteur local important
dont certaines réalisations apparaissent
emblématiques je pense notamment à la
tour bois le prêtre sous la direction
des architectes Anne la Caton et
Jean-Philippe Vassal mesdames messieurs
je souhaite que cette audition nous
permette d'avoir une vision plus claire
des enjeux de la rénovation énergétique
du parc social qui est soumis au même
calendrier que le logement privé quelle
est la situation du parc en France dans
les quartiers et à Paris les bailleurs
sociaux éventuellement avec l'appui de
l'enrue sont-ils en mesure de relever le
défi du calendrier de la loi climat
résilience
quels sont les montants d'investissement
à programmer le chiffre de
8,6 milliards d'euros par an a été
évoqué le confirmez-vous est-ce
réalisable dans un contexte de RLS de
hausse du taux du livret A et de
l'endettement global du secteur et de
hausse de cou des travaux
nous avons pu visiter en Isère dans le
département du rapporteur à
L'Isle-d'Abeau une rénovation HLM menée
par Action Logement d'un coup de plus de
60 000 euros par logement je sais que
cette équation financière sans être
générale n'est pas isolé est-ce
soutenable ce besoin de rénovation
peut-il se conjuguer avec le besoin de
construire de nouveaux logements sociaux
qui certes n'est pas dans le champ de
notre commission d'enquête mais que je
ne peux et surtout que je ne veux pas
occulter par ailleurs comme la souligner
Antoine Peillon le secrétaire général à
la planification écologique que nous
avons auditionné devant notre commission
d'enquête la semaine dernière et comme
nous y incite la directive européenne
sur la décarbonation des bâtiments en
cours de discussion n’étant pas conduit
à faire un choix stratégique entre une
décarbon rapide et une recherche de
sobriété sur plus long terme compte tenu
du coup de la complexité et du temps
nécessaire à des rénovations globales
dans ce cadre comment évolue les
réflexions en matière de seconde vie du
parc social et de stratégie du
patrimoine dont l'expérimentation est
adossée à un appel à manifestation qui a
été lancé manifestée en intérêt qui a
été lancé tout récemment par le
ministère de la transition écologique et
peut-être vous pourrez nous en dire plus
sur ce sujet du côté de l'enru comment
s'insère ces enjeux entre rénovation
très profonde et reconstruction neuve
qui était plus dans l'ADN de l'agence en
quoi l'initiative quartier résilient
constitue-t-elle une inflexion et
l'agence conserve-t-elle les moyens
nécessaires à son action définit de
manière forfaitaire dans le contexte
inflationniste que nous connaissons
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre à ses premières questions et
pour un propos introductif environ une
quinzaine de minutes mais bon vous
l'aurez partie c'est comme vous
l'entendez et on peut bien sûr largement
le dépasser il me revient de vous
indiquer que cette audition est diffusée
en direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat est un compte-rendu
sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure j'ai oublié
de spécifier que donc accompagner la
présidente monsieur Alban charrier qui
adjoint au directeur de la maîtrise
d'ouvrage je veux dire en même temps et
des politiques patrimoniales de l'usage
et si vous êtes amené à prendre la
parole je vous demanderai également de
vous soumettre au même formalisme donc
on commence par vous monsieur monaza
je vous en remercie donc je vous laisse
la parole pour répartir comme vous le
souhaitez peut-être que c'est la
présidente qui peut peut-être intervenir
et puis ensuite notre rapporteur vous
posera un certain nombre de questions
ainsi que les membres de la commission
d'enquête qui ont bien voulu nous
rejoindre c'est à vous merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs c'est
notre société sénateurs
tout d'abord je vous remercie pour cette
table ronde et pour un focus spécifique
sur le logement social car évidemment
sur tout l'enjeu de la rénovation du
bâtiment et de la décarbonation le
système même du logement social les
loyers qui sont pratiqués le public que
l'on éloge pose des questions qui sont
spécifiques et il nous semble important
de pouvoir vous présenter ces
spécificités mais aussi nos
positionnements et et comment est-ce
qu'on veut faire face à cet enjeu très
clair mais de la décarbonation du parc
résidentiel qui est pour nous
extrêmement important
peut-être avant de rentrer dans le
détail et je vais aussi en même temps
Madame la Présidente de répondre à une
certaine note de vos questions puis
après évidemment vous poser des
questions vous dire quelques éléments
importants que vous ayez en tête donc le
parc du parc du logement social qui est
donc constitué par le PACS le parc de
logement porté par les organismes HLM et
les SEM c'est autour de 5 millions cinq
logements on est sur une base
actuellement d'à peu près à 4,8 millions
de logements familiaux mais il faut pas
oublier
cette masse autour de 500 000 logements
qui sont dits les logements accompagnés
ou gérés dans lesquels vous allez
retrouver logement étudiant résidence
pour personnes âgées foyers c'est très
important parce que vous allez voir ils
sont totalement absents y compris de la
data
des des statistiques et c'est une
bataille que nous menons pour y compris
renseigner ces enjeux là car ils ont été
complètement oubliés notamment de des
statistiques qui ont été construits
notamment le calendrier de rénovation
deuxième
constat à faire
qui a été montré à plusieurs reprises
par l'ardem par le Plan Bâtiment etc
c'est que le parc social est en général
plus performant
si on regarde l'ancien DPE je vous dis
ça parce qu'on a des statistiques pas
assez consolidés là en 2023 sur le
nouveau DPE mais le parc social est plus
performant d'un point de vue énergétique
que l'ensemble du parc privé donc c'est
très important que vous ayez ça en tête
c'est à dire que les passoires
énergétiques les plus énergivores il y
en a évidemment dans le parc social mais
il y en a beaucoup moins que dans le
parc privé on est sur des pourcentages
beaucoup plus faibles
et par contre la difficulté pour le parc
social ça va être que par ailleurs on
n'a pas énormément de parcs ultra
performant c'est à dire les classes AOB
et donc on a beaucoup de patrimoine qui
va être situé dans les classes E D et C
mais il est important que vous ayez ça
en tête parce que ça permet aussi de
comprendre que comme ce patrimoine
depuis très longtemps c'est pas nouveau
c'est que le patrimoine social qui est
ancien
il y a quasiment un tiers qui a été fait
avant les années 75 un gros tiers qui
est fait entre 75 et 90 c'est quand même
deux tiers qui est du patrimoine qui est
d'avant les années 90 et il y a une
partie évidemment qui est d'avant 1945
on est sur des patrimoines qui sont
plutôt anciens qui ont déjà fait l'objet
de réhabilitation parce que il y a quand
même dans le parc dans le patrimoine
social une culture de la réhabilitation
c'est à dire je parle pas de
réhabilitation énergétique mais
l'habitude qui est des travaux des
changements de composantes
l'arrivée un moment
des salles de bains enfin on a fait pas
mal de de d'évolution dans ce patrimoine
depuis évidemment des décennies et donc
c'est un patrimoine qui a bénéficié de
travaux depuis bien plus longtemps que
beaucoup d'autres patrimoines ce qui
explique certainement qu'ils soient
moins énergivore par ailleurs c'était du
patrimoine qui a aussi bénéficié qui ont
été construit parfois de d'avancer
technologique
qui ont plus ou moins bien fonctionné
après mais je pense l'arrivée de la
géothermique et énormément utilisée dans
les dans les quartiers d'habitat social
dans les années 50 ou 60 les réseaux de
chaleur urbaines il y a eu beaucoup de
choses comme ça qui sont arrivées et
plus récemment les premières centrales
biomasses sont aussi arrivées dans le
parc social avant d'aller dans du parc
privé résidentiel donc ça explique qu'on
est on n'a pas exactement la même
sensibilité que le reste du parc
résidentiel sur les questions de
rénovation néanmoins
lorsque la loi climat est résilience a
pour la première fois tracé un
calendrier d'obligation de rénovation le
mouvement Hlm a plutôt eu pour position
de dire que d'une part on partageait
l'ambition de la décarbonation du parc
et deuxièmement qu'on était prêt à
relever le défi
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que comme nous gérons ce patrimoine sur
des décennies et voir sur des siècles
puisqu'on a du patrimoine qui a
quasiment 100 ans aujourd'hui
il y a un enjeu pour nous d'améliorer
toujours la qualité de ce patrimoine y
compris pour que nos locataires qui
vivent dedans ne soient pas sujets à des
niveaux de charge extrêmement lourds
deuxièmement en tant que bailleur social
et vu notre poids je dirais dans le la
politique du logement en tout cas tel
que nous le défendons et y compris
on estime qu'on doit on doit être parti
prenantes de l'enjeu de la décarbonation
quand on a la tête d'un patrimoine d'eau
autour de 5 ou 5 millions de logements
qui représentent peu ou proue c'est 18%
des résidences principales nous estimons
en tant qu'acteur
de du logement à avoir un rôle à jouer
particulier là-dessus et y compris on
l'assumait à plusieurs congrès à chez
elle à vouloir assumer le fait d'être un
des leaders de la décarbonation du parc
résidentiel je dis ça parce que j'ai été
moi-même une des seules actrices du
logement dans des discussions
ministériales sur le sujet à défendre le
calendrier
non pas parce que je pense qu'il est bon
ou mauvais c'est à dire qu'à un moment
où la représentation nationale avait
fixé un calendrier en dans le texte de
cas de dans le cadre de ce texte de loi
j'ai estimé qu'il était à nous de notre
devoir d'essayer d'y répondre et de ne
pas avoir un jugement a priori en disant
ce calendrier est impossible ou c'est
trop compliqué
y compris parce que l'avantage entre
guillemets d'avoir ce calendrier qui est
assez dur c'est qui permet de créer une
dynamique de créer une trajectoire et
que les bailleurs sociaux quittera qui
vont envisager leur réhabilitation non
pas sur trois ans on fait des plans à 5
ans à 10 ans à 30 ans on regarde la
fiabilité financière de nos organismes
sur cette durée là donc avoir cette
trajectoire elle nous permet aussi de
voir loin et de se dire à partir des
jalons qui sont donnés 2025 2028 2034 de
voir comment est-ce qu'on y va
et ça a toujours été notre position et
ça l'est toujours aujourd'hui
après pour dire les choses franchement
est-ce qu'on est en mesure de relever le
défi d'un point de vue politique et d'un
point de vue social nous le sommes la
question c'est ce qu'on a l'outil les
outils pour le faire et c'est là que la
classique les situations sont
compliquées
et moi je pense qu'on va être capable de
relever la marche de 2025 et de 2028
mais je sais quand même qu'il y a de
nombreuses difficultés et je vais
peut-être les expliquer en quel moment
déjà sur la
comment dire sur la manière dont cette
réforme de la loi climatisée cette
réforme elle est basée sur deux
principes qui est tout à fait nouveau
dans le logement la première c'est
qu'elle donne une obligation de
rénovation basée sur un outil qui est le
DPE un nouveau DPE
donc qui prend deux étiquettes
l'étiquette énergétique et l'étiquette
carbone l'étiquette énergétique qu'il y
a la consommation du bâtiment
l'étiquette carbone qui est liée au
vecteur de l'énergie utilisée
donc
l'électricité gaz ou tout ça un nouveau
DPE qui dans la réforme qui arrive donc
au premier juillet 2021 un nouveau DPE
qui n'existe pas à l'époque un premier
arrêté modificatif sur le DPE arrive en
octobre 2021 puis on nous dit que les
logiciels des diagnostiqueurs ne seront
pas validés ne le sont que le 31 mars
2022 en sachant bien que la première
marche est 2025
et donc on nous a demandé en fait de
commencer une stratégie de rénovation
avec un outil qui n'existait pas
sans que l'on sache en fait en tant que
bailleur quel était la nature des
étiquettes nous vous dépe de l'ensemble
de notre patrimoine et avec des outils
et des diagnostiqueurs qui ne pouvaient
pas assurer qu'ils étaient capables de
fournir le l'outil qui est opposable
puisque c'est le grand changement de la
loi et donc je vous cache pas que ces
deux ans d'atermoiements sur un outil
pas totalement maîtrisé
une difficulté de fait à faire les
marchés pour relancer les diagnostics a
été assez compliqué et ça explique aussi
que beaucoup de bailleurs ont lancé ce
qu'on appelle des campagnes de nouveaux
DPE depuis un an mais certains ont
arrivés à avoir 50% de nouveaux DPE
d'autres ne sont qu'à 30 il y a des
endroits on a des problèmes avec les
diagnostiqueurs et il y a d'autres
endroits où on a des difficultés
importantes alors on pourrait se dire
c'est pas grave on a le temps mais sauf
qu'en fait une réhabilitation vous la
faites pas en un an et en plus vous
devez projeter ses travaux et donc
aujourd'hui en 2023 ne pas connaître
encore l'ENT ièreté des nouveaux DPE de
notre patrimoine pour juger de la
stratégie pour 2025 à 28 c'est déjà un
peu juste pour dire les choses très
franchement par ailleurs une partie du
patrimoine social n'était pas soumis au
DPE avant cette réforme notamment du
patrimoine
qui datait d'avant la Première Guerre
mondiale on est très clair c'était
patrimoine qui sont essentiellement
Angers mais si je vous en parle c'est
que ces patrimoine là ils étaient pas
comptabilisés dans les statistiques
d'usiness jusque là et que donc quand le
système de statistiques a sorti des
datas au parlementaires quand vous avez
discuté de ce texte de loi on était en
fait sur des anciens DPE et sur une base
statistique qui était
erronée
et je vous cache pas que s'il y avait
une étude d'impact sur cette partie là
du texte de loi certainement qu'on
aurait pu de fait affiner beaucoup plus
les choses l'autre difficulté qu'il faut
comprendre c'est ce changement de
pratique puisque au-delà de l'obligation
de rénovation qui est inscrite dans la
loi et qui permet de booster créer une
dynamique
c'est aussi que c'est le DPE qui dit à
partir 2021 si le logement est considéré
comme descend ou pas ce qui est très
nouveau pour les bailleurs sociaux car
jusque là la problématique de la décence
d'un logement était quelque chose que
l'on connaissait peu et vous comprenez
bien que la décence d'un logement est-ce
que prévoit la loi aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si
le logement s'il est indécent c'est
l'arrêt des allocations familiales des
aPL c'est peut-être des négociations sur
la minoration de loyer mais ça pose des
questions évidemment très nouvelles et
notamment nous notre patrimoine il est
habité il n'est pas vide et c'est ça
aussi une des questions qui se pose
c'est que on
des difficultés aujourd'hui d'une part
donc avoir les bons DPE je vous cache
pas qu'il y a quand même des locataires
qui n'ouvrent pas la porte pour que les
DPE soit fait que maintenant les
bailleurs ont commencé à faire des
procédures contentieuses auprès de leur
locataire pour qu'on puisse rentrer
puisqu'en fait sinon le diagnostiqueur
estime qu'il n'a pas assez d'éléments
probants et donc dans ce cas-là il met
des données de base mais qui vont être
assez éloignés en fait de la performance
du bâtiment et ce qui explique en fait
une une difficulté assez importante
néanmoins quand même que vous l'ayez en
tête dans les statistiques qu'on avait
au 1er janvier 2022 et je suis
extrêmement prudente sur les
statistiques que je vous donne et on
vous les redonnera dans le questionnaire
qu'on vous renverra sur 4 millions 55
000 de logements on avait 3 % du
patrimoine qui était considérés comme
étant en G
7% en F
et puis 21% en eux 33% des 34% en C donc
ça vous donne une idée en gros le gros
du patrimoine étant CD
on a on estimait qu'on avait un 30 % qui
était en EFG mais en fait 20% eux et 10%
F et G et puis 5% en a et b
donc avec évidemment et je le redis
aussi une répartition qu'évidemment pas
homogène sur le territoire d'une part le
logement social n'a pas une répartition
de répartition homogène sur le
territoire mais pareil le patrimoine de
plus ancien se trouve dans liste dans
les territoires qui ont une très forte
histoire industrielle française donc ils
sont dans le Grand Est dans les hauts de
France en Île-de-France et un peu
évidemment en Rhône-Alpes et aussi un
peu en PACA mais c'est quand même plus
récent et donc les étiquettes dégradées
sont plutôt là où le patrimoine est le
plus ancien ce qui est évidemment
important le dire aussi mais je pense
que la directrice de Lorient aura des
chiffres un peu plus précis les
quartiers en enrue ne sont pas les
quartiers les plus énergivores sont des
quartiers d'habitat social qui sont
plutôt des années 50-60 70 il y a des
endroits il y a du patrimoine énergivore
mais en général il plutôt en moyenne en
D et on ne le réhabilite surtout pour
des problèmes
urbains la question énergétique peut
arriver là mais c'est pas toujours
évidemment
le sujet
donc à partir de là la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui sur comment comment
est-ce qu'on avance
d'une part
je pense qu'une des difficultés ça a été
en effet d'avoir un outil sur lequel est
basé le calendrier de la loi qui n'est
pas qui n'était pas tout à fait
utilisable alors même qu'il est
opposable et pas tout à fait fiable je
pense que là actuellement ça va beaucoup
mieux mais ça veut dire qu'on aura je
pense seulement fin 2023 une image qui
commence à être exhaustive du patrimoine
social
la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme travaux et là
arrive les questions y compris que vous
posez autour notamment de ce qu'a pu
dire Antoine Peillon ce que vous avez
deux sujets vous avez la question de
répondre à la précarité énergétique
qu'il y a la dépense de la consommation
et donc on peut penser que les logements
F et G en effet sont très consommateurs
donc il y a des charges plus importantes
et donc il faut permettre une plus
grande sobriété mais décarboner ça veut
surtout dire changer le vecteur
d'énergie
la décarbonation ne pose pas la question
de la sobriété elle pose uniquement la
question de savoir si l'énergie utilisée
est une énergie carbonée ou pas et c'est
là où on arrive sur la seconde
difficulté du patrimoine social qui est
là par contre très particulière
c'est le fait que nous avons un
patrimoine qui est très carboné pourquoi
puisque en gros
et alors pareil on reste prudent sur les
statistiques que l'on va vous donner
mais que nous estimons quand même
relativement fiables donc nous estimons
qu'il y a seulement 20% de notre
patrimoine qui est chauffé à
l'électricité
3% ou bois et puis après nous avons 54%
du réseau du du patrimoine qui est
chauffé au gaz de ville ou de réseau 2%
au fioul ce qui reste beaucoup quand
fait 2% de 5 millions de logements et
20% au chauffage urbain
et dans le chauffage urbain vous allez
avoir des réseaux qui sont plutôt très
peu carbonées aujourd'hui et d'autres
qui le sont encore beaucoup et donc ça
c'est la seconde difficulté c'est que on
a un patrimoine qui est par rapport au
patrimoine national privé beaucoup plus
chauffé au gaz parce que les pouvoirs
publics ont incité l'ensemble des
bailleurs sociaux avec chauffés au gaz
c'est le résultat de politique mené par
le passé et encore assez récente et donc
sur le vecteur de l'énergie la question
de la décarbonation évidemment la
question qui se pose c'est comment
est-ce qu'on se désensibilise au gaz
alors je vous cache pas que le débat sur
les prix de l'énergie ces dernières
années notamment ces derniers mois a un
peu aidé à se rendre compte qu'il
fallait de toute façon que les bailleurs
sociaux
essaient en fait de d'avoir plus de mix
énergétiques sur leur sujet mais ça
c'est une de nos difficultés et c'est
peut-être ça une des difficultés de la
question de la rénovation c'est que vous
pouvez faire tous les travaux que vous
voulez si votre vecteur il reste très
carboné vous ne répondez pas à la
question de la décarbonation et la
question c'est d'arriver à trouver un
mixte et c'est pour ça que sur la
question des vecteurs je vous cache pas
notamment dans le débat actuel sur la
question du réseau électrique je ne suis
pas certaine que RTE attendent que nous
rajoutions plus de 2 millions 5 de
logements sur le réseau électrique je le
dis franchement donc la question est
plutôt de savoir d'une part est-ce qu'on
peut raccorder plus de logements au
réseau de chaleur et ça c'est un combat
que nous menons beaucoup et je pense que
nous avons pas mal progressé mais c'est
pour nous quelque chose d'essentiel
notamment parce que ces réseaux se
décarbonent extrêmement rapidement
deuxièmement est-ce que demain parce que
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui est-ce que
demain par exemple dans la future
programmation pluralienne de l'énergie
nous aurons accès à plus de biogaz pour
chauffer le parc HLM
enfin est-ce que dans le cadre de
l'accélération sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables le patrimoine
social puisse être un acteur important
du développement des énergies
renouvelables je pense évidemment on
souffre biomasse mais ça peut être
évidemment le soleil et plein d'autres
choses évidemment qu'il faut faire les
travaux de sobriété mais malgré tout
faudra bien mettre de l'énergie dans une
partie de notre patrimoine et donc il
faut aussi travailler sur cette
décarbonation qui ne passera pas que par
un changement de tout le gaz vers
l'électrique en fait on sait que c'est
aujourd'hui extrêmement peu extrêmement
compliqué ça pose néanmoins des
questions et y compris voyez des
questions en règlementaires pas facile
juste vous donner un exemple les réseaux
de chaleur en fait
évolue tous les ans les collectivités
font des efforts très importants
aujourd'hui pour faire dire les réseaux
de chaleur sauf que dans le DPE le
diagnostiqueur pour faire son DPE il va
regarder ce que dit un arrêté
donc le dernier arrêté on a attendu 18
mois pour qu'il soit pris qui va vous
dire tel réseau de chaleur à tel endroit
voici son vecteur énergétique voici son
comment il est calculé et en fait s'est
arrêté s'il est pas pris annuellement et
qu'il est pas mis à jour ça veut dire
que vous avez des DPE qui sont faits sur
des calculs qui sont faux mais ça pose
des normes questions parce que à la fin
pour le bailleur vous pouvez avoir un
patrimoine qui de fait comme il est mal
mis à jour au niveau de la data se
retrouve en indécence donc pour nous
c'est des anges c'est pas juste des
petits enjeux administratifs c'est des
enjeux réglementaires de savoir si
demain on peut mettre le patrimoine
évidemment en location alors ce que nous
évidemment on préconise je vois que je
suis trop longue donc je vais essayer de
m'arrêter là ce qu'on préconise c'est
quoi c'est un une stabilité du cadre de
la trajectoire donc notamment du
calendrier nous on ne milite pas du tout
pour un
une détente du calendrier nous pensons
que le calendrier est là la question
c'est les moyens qui nous permettent de
le faire
donc une stabilité une visibilité
financière parce que la difficulté on en
avait déjà parlé dans le cas de ma
première audition c'est évidemment de
pouvoir faire un plan de rénovation à 5
ou 10 ans quand on ne sait pas chaque
année ce que l'on a pour comme aide en
subvention en C2E en fiscalité et c'est
une des très grosses difficultés puisque
aujourd'hui nous faisons des plantes
financement dont nous ne savons pas ce
qu'ils vont être je parle même pas de la
question du taux du livret A puisque
certes le taux du livret A ça a un
impact sur nos opérations neuves mais ça
aussi un impact sur nos opérations de
réhabilitation puisque nous contractons
des nouveaux prêts à cette occasion
donc visibilité stabilité et puis
appuie technique et appui de filière
parce que alors beaucoup de vos
questions ont porté sur les écho
matériaux
sur notamment dans la dans le cadre de
la réhabilitation
aujourd'hui nous pensons que toute façon
faut accélérer le rythme de la
rénovation dans le logement social à mon
avis de au moins un tiers voir la moitié
et donc ça veut dire d'ailleurs une
filière qui est prête à répondre à
l'ensemble de nos marchés moi je pense
qu'elle est prête mais ça veut quand
même dire que ça se travaille ça se
planifie ça veut dire certainement que
régionalement ou même par niveau
départemental les bailleurs soient
capables de présenter à l'ensemble des
acteurs du bâtiment les plans de charge
qui sont prévus puisque là je vous parle
quand même de réhabilité un million de
logements dans dans les 10 ans ce qui
est quand même beaucoup et après la
question c'est quel moyen et évidemment
là on va retrouver un débat qui m'oppose
fortement actuellement avec les services
du ministère du Logement c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans la réhabilitation est-ce
qu'on ne répond que à l'enjeu climat
résilience donc on ne s'attaque que à la
réalisation énergétique et donc on
rentre dans les cases pour être hors de
l'un des sens donc au moins arriver en
classe D où la location de cette
réhabilitation on en profite pour
adapter les salles de bains refaire les
cuisines et toutes les salles les zones
humides n'ont pas été faites depuis 30
ou 40 ans on refait les parties communes
on résidancialise enfin on est fait
évoluer le patrimoine et c'est là où on
revient sur la question du coup au
logement alors oui 60 000 euros au
logement objectivement dans une
rénovation énergétique qui fait au moins
deux classes un gain de classe c'est
vraiment la moyenne je dirais même dans
certains patrimoine plutôt bassins on
est en train l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat a relancé une enquête la flash
auprès des opérateurs pour avoir les
coûts à vous de 2022 donc on voulait
transmettre à l'enquête sera ce qu'on a
pas terminée quand on l'aura mais
évidemment
si vous isolez la partie énergétique
vous pouvez dire que ça vaut 30000 euros
mais après ça dépend combien de classes
vous devez gagner est-ce que vous êtes
sur un patrimoine sur une tour qui a
seulement quatre faces et en fait vous
n'avez que quatre faces à traiter ou
vous êtes sur une résidence de petit
bâtiment de deux étages ou sur du
patrimoine individuel puisque nous avons
quand même 12% de patrimoine individuel
et donc oui l'écoute travaux moi je vois
des dossiers tous les jours ça va de
20000 euros pour certains à 100000 euros
pour d'autres et je parle hors en rue et
c'est une des difficultés c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on va mener des travaux
sur du patrimoine donc parfois les coûts
travaux pour faire une rénovation
énergétique qui permet de gagner au
moins deux classes énergétiques sont
souvent supérieures à la moitié de la
valeur du bien telle qu'il estimé au
domaine
et là vous pourrez m'interroger de
savoir est-ce que ça a du sens de
réhabiliter ces logements plutôt que
d'en acheter d'autres ou de ne plus les
mettre en location c'est tout à fait le
débat le débat du moment enfin sur la
seconde vie donc certes un appel à
projet lancé par le ministère du
logement mais la seconde vie c'est un
projet qui a été créé porté inventée par
l'Union sociale pour l'habitat et la
Caisse des Dépôts notre idée elle a été
de se dire que aujourd'hui
notamment on a des enjeux évidemment de
diminuer les émissions carbone y compris
de la démolition que la seconde vie
c'est l'idée de redonner une seconde vie
totale à un bâtiment et de faire ce qui
se fait beaucoup dans le patrimoine de
bureau c'est à dire de désosser
totalement des structures de bureau de
garder en fait que la les structures
porteuses et de refaire tout y compris
les niveaux de plancher les hauteurs et
aujourd'hui l'idée de la seconde vie
c'est d'avoir un mode de financement qui
allie
des financements qui sont liés à la
rénovation mais donc des prêts qui
soient plus longs que ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui qui sont des prêts sur 25
ans qui soit allongés mais qui
permettent d'avoir en même temps des
aides qui correspondent à du à du
logement neuf et qui nous permet de
répondre à des programmes d'habitat très
particuliers il y a plein d'exemples de
seconde vie ça a été beaucoup fait à
Paris ça a été beaucoup fait dans la rue
mais que des modèles économiques qui
étaient en fait assez faibles et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire qu'on a du
patrimoine qu'on va vider entièrement
qu'on va complètement revoir
l'enveloppe
la composition ça nous permet aussi de
changer des T5 anciens trop grands des
surfaces plus petites et par contre de
recharger ce patrimoine pour 50 80 100
ans de nouvelle vie
mais en limitant évidemment les effets
d'une démolition sur et donc des
émissions carbone je dois être
extrêmement précise la seconde vie c'est
pas ça qui permet de réhabiter tout le
parc c'est une petite niche importante
pour du patrimoine qui est plutôt du
patrimoine collectif
en gros essentiellement des années 50 à
80 et qui nous permet ou alors du
patrimoine ancien parisien mais je
laisserai directeur de la FVP y répondre
et qui permet vraiment de faire
quasiment de refaire de l'offre neuve
donc pour nous c'est un nouvel outil
mais c'est pas avec ça qu'on va qu'on va
régler tout le problème on a lancé là
une expérimentation pour voir notamment
le niveau des coûts travaux à cette
échelle
de travaux de voir aussi en fonction des
des années de construction qu'est-ce
qu'on est capable de faire et surtout
quel est le niveau de performance demain
de ce patrimoine parce que là aussi où
vous pourriez demain nous interroger
c'est de savoir à quel niveau on arrive
en termes de réhabilitation et je vais
dire les choses franchement si on n'a
pas de visibilité financière
durable sur les moyens à louer au
secteur HLM pour financer des travaux
on fera les travaux qui nous permettent
de rester dans la loi donc de sortir les
logements de l'indécence mais par
exemple on amènera des logements en
classe D mais on n'ira pas en classe C
parce qu'il faudra rajouter 10.000 euros
par logement qu'on n'est pas capable de
financer et donc et vous allez et vous
trouverez et vous aurez raison que c'est
complètement idiot de ne pas être
capable d'aller un peu plus loin dans la
performance pour une question financière
mais on en est là aujourd'hui et très
sincèrement
y compris dans la situation financière
actuelle du logement social c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de discussions
internes dans les organismes de savoir
est-ce que ça fait sens de mettre 90 000
euros dans la réputation d'un logement
nous pensons que oui mais néanmoins ça
se discute certains élus locaux nous
interrogent est-ce que ce patrimoine va
vraiment être cloué encore pendant 50
ans
parce que c'est pas les loyers des
locataires qui financent qui finançant
ses travaux c'est des emprunts c'est des
subventions des collectivités locales
c'est de la fiscalité
et des dégrèvements de TFPB donc je
pense qu'il est important d'avoir ça en
tête et c'est un peu ça en fait
aujourd'hui
en conclusion de mon intervention trop
longue je m'en excuse
ce que j'aimerais vous dire c'est que
nous on veut être les leaders de ce
sujet là en fait on veut y aller c'est
le message que je tiens depuis 2020 très
clairement en disant que on prend le
calendrier tel qu'il est maintenant on y
va la question c'est qu'on est les
moyens financiers de faire parce que
techniquement on sait faire
techniquement on sait faire en plus nous
on est propriétaire de notre patrimoine
donc en fait à part la partie
campropriété qui est vraiment un petit
sujet en réalité on sait lancer les
travaux on est chez nous donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile on n'a pas les
mêmes difficultés dans le parc privé que
dans les copropriétés mais mais il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est quand même
dans une absence de visibilité y compris
je vous le dis franchement je sais même
pas comment on va financer enfin quel
est le la maquette financière des
programmes de réhabilitation pour 2024
donc c'est un peu difficile à partir de
ce moment là de se dire qu'on est
capable de suivre la trajectoire
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente pour
ses propos très précis comment votre
habitude est très documenté Madame la
Directrice générale on va vous laisser
la parole
merci beaucoup
ma présence de se rapporte mesdames
messieurs alors quelques
éléments peut-être déjà pour préciser le
périmètre d'intervention de l'enrue
étant donné que par rapport à ce que
Madame la présente de l'usage vient de
présenter nous intervenons sur 450
quartiers sur les 1500 quartiers
politiques de la ville donc ça
représente à peu près 850 000 logements
sociaux donc on est sur une échelle qui
est bien évidemment moins moins
importante que celle qui vient d'être
évoquée de manière précise pas madame la
Présidente de l'USH
quelques mots mais vous le savez sur le
fait que
l'ADN de la rue et l'intervention et les
modalités d'intervention de la rue dans
la loi vous avez rappelé du 1er août
2003 était notamment de se fonder sur
deux grands piliers la mixité sociale et
la construction et la participation de
la ville durable avec cette marque de
fabrique de lanrupt de refaire la ville
sur la ville d'essayer d'apporter des
réponses sur des quartiers de manière
globale à la fois certainement sur les
sujets d'habitat mais aussi sur les
sujets d'aménagement d'équipements et
donc de prendre en compte la globalité
d'une intervention sur un quartier et
pas uniquement d'intervenir sur le
logement social comme
je vous l'ai dit peut-être une précision
sur la rénovation des logements sociaux
donc dans le cas du NP NRU donc du
deuxième programme quelques chiffres
pour vous donner les grands éléments
nous intervenons pour traiter environ
250 000 logements sur les 250 000
logements nous nous intervenons pour
financer
105.000 démolition de logements sociaux
et 140
000 à peu près en réhabilitation lourde
je reviendrai sur le sujet
réhabilitation lourde parce que un des
éléments d'évolution entre le premier
programme et le deuxième programme qui
répond à une interrogation que vous avez
posé en introduction c'est le fait que
nous avons
choisi dans le deuxième programme de
financer peut-être moins de
réhabilitation mais sur des niveaux
beaucoup plus qualitatifs donc des
restructurations lourdes et donc on a un
niveau moyen d'intervention sur les
restructurations qui est beaucoup plus
important c'est à dire qu'on est à peu
près à fois 6 par rapport à ce qu'on
faisait sur le PNRU on était plutôt sur
des interventions qui relèvent de
l'entretien du patrimoine on est
beaucoup plus maintenant sur des
restructurations lourdes et même sur les
dernières structurations je ne peux que
confirmer les chiffres qui ont été
donnés par Emmanuel cosse à l'instant
nous sommes sur des niveaux extrêmement
significatifs qui vont jusqu'à 80.000
cent mille euros au logement sur des
restructurations l'autre quand on a lit
rénovation énergétique à BBC rénaux
minimum voire BBC renommé -10 - 20 selon
les programmes et on pourra y revenir et
aussi restructuration interne parce que
souvent quand on intervient en
restructuration on fait tout et on
intervient à la fois sur l'enjeu
thermique énergétique mais aussi sur les
questions d'habitabilité et de
restructuration interne des logements
mais j'y reviendrai donc 250
000 logements qui sont traités donc
logement donc 105 000 logements sociaux
140 logement réhabilitation est à peu
près 8000 logements privés je le
mentionne pour que vous l'ayez en tête
et puis on participe bien sûr aussi à la
reconstruction de logements on
reconstruction de logements sociaux donc
là étiquette a avec la belle classiques
et à la construction aussi de logements
en diversification au-delà de ces
interventions sur l'habitat la rue
finance plus de 1000 équipes en public
vous savez l'aménagement d'un grand
nombre d'hectares de terrain pour
revenir au sujet du logement social dans
le cadre de du travail qui a été fait
sur le NPN rue nous sommes beaucoup
préoccupés mais c'était aussi ce que
madame la Présidente viendra rappeler
sur l'évolution des DPE sur la question
de la sobriété énergétique et sur la
question de la rénovation thermique et
donc un des enjeux en termes de
financement de la rue ça a été d'inciter
notamment dans nos financements les
bailleurs allaient plutôt vers le BBC
Réno avec des financements majorés pour
les interventions en BBC rénovation
plutôt que d'intervenir en HPE et
aujourd'hui on finance 70% de nos réhab
en BBC rénaux ce qui montre les forces
significatives que nous avons fait et
dans le cadre de l'abondement de
milliards d'euros vous le savez qui a
été décidé en 2021 par le gouvernement
du programme du nouveau programme de
renouvellement urbain nous avons décidé
de ne plus financer que des
réhabilitations au niveau de
labellisation BBC rénaux ce qui va
conduire ce pourcentage à évolué donc
c'est vraiment un souhait extrêmement
fort en termes de performance
énergétique
après dans le cadre de nos réflexions et
de la mise en oeuvre du npre qui est là
vraiment en phase opérationnelle ainsi
quelques éléments peut-être
d'actualité sur le npre on est en fin
d'allocation c'est-à-dire que tous les
crédits du nperu sont alloués on a donc
tous les quartiers qui ont fait l'objet
d'une validation de projets et on a à
peu près plus de 440 quartiers qui sont
en chantier sur les 450 donc là on est
en phase opérationnelle extrêmement
active
et dans le cadre de cette phase
opérationnelle la réflexion que nous
avons conduit avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires bien sûr l'USH Action
Logement la Caisse des Dépôts mais aussi
un certain nombre d'agences d'états et
je tiens à le souligner et je reviendrai
sur ce point nous avons souhaité dans le
cas de la mise en oeuvre du npru
réinterroger les projets à l'aune de la
résilience pour nous poser la question
de savoir si on avait bien par rapport
aux enjeux la loi climat résilience et
aux enjeux de la résilience plus
globalement dans les programmes que nous
étions en train de déployer répondu à
l'ensemble des enjeux qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui et qui sont
particulièrement cruciaux et ça nous a
conduit notamment à nous interroger
beaucoup plus fortement qu'au départ sur
la question de la production d'énergie
et du mode d'alimentation en énergie des
quartiers un sujet qui était assez peu
traité jusqu'à maintenant dans le cadre
des programmes de renouvellement urbain
et nous avons dans ce cadre-là renforcé
notre partenariat avec l'ADEME et vous
avez dû le voir dans les annonces qui
ont été faites sur le programme quartier
résilient la dame s'est engagé à mettre
chaque année 50 millions d'euros à
minima sur les projets de renouvellement
urbain qui vont être accompagnés de
manière renforcée pour permettre de
traiter ces questions
d'approvisionnement en énergie sur
lesquels il nous semble que nous devons
aller plus loin et pour revenir
rapidement sur les éléments de
diagnostic mais la présidente de l'USH
les a indiqué à l'instant on constate
que d'après les chiffres on a encore on
est en train nous aussi statistiquement
on travaille avec le SH sur l'analyse
précise de la fin de l'état du parc de
logements social dans les quartiers
npres on constate que on a un patrimoine
qui est plutôt bien positionné en
matière en matière énergétique et en
matière thermique pour en matière
d'isolation parce qu'il y a aussi des
travaux qui ont été faits et les années
de construction
conduisent effectivement à ce qu'il soit
plutôt classé en dés même si on a
quelques logements qui sont en étiquette
EF et g par contre on a un vrai sujet
sur
énergétique c'est à dire que le mode
d'approvisionnement mais ça a été dit je
ne fais que paraphraser ce qui a été dit
est essentiellement au gaz et donc on a
un enjeu de développement des réseaux de
chauffage urma c'est un enjeu qui est
extrêmement important et je ne peux
qu'approuver ce que disait la présidente
sur les sujets des arrêtés par rapport
au classement des réseaux de chauffage
urbain on a parfois des bailleurs qui
sont venus nous dire qu'ils allaient se
déracer du réseau de chauffage urbain
parce qu'il n'était pas classé vert et
qui ne pouvait pas atteindre les
objectifs BBC rénaux en restant
raccordés au chauffage urbain et donc
c'est un exemple sur lequel la mère de
la ville est venue nous voir et nous
avons convenu que nous suspendions le
projet le temps que le réseau se
verdissent pour que éviter des
raccordements et permettre de garder une
performance globale du système je cite
cet exemple parce que ça a été vraiment
le fondement de notre réflexion sur
quartier résilient quartier résilient
c'est une démarche en deux en deux
volets très rapidement en premier volet
c'est de se dire que tous les projets de
renouvellement urbain dans le cadre des
revues de projets que nous menons chaque
année on doit faire l'objet d'une
analyse au titre de la résilience pour
vérifier si les grands enjeux sont bien
respectés et deuxième chose à une
accompagnement renforcée de 50
territoires sur lesquels des
problématiques croisées de
dysfonctionnement urbain
environnementaux et sociaux se posent et
sur ces 50 territoires nous avons déjà
retenu 25 territoires d'intervention en
forcés sur ces 25 territoires un quart
nous pose des questions relatives au
sujet d'énergie et nous demande une
intervention renforcée sur ces sujets là
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée des
denjeux qui sont posés et donc c'est
tout le sens du partenariat qu'on a
engagé avec l'ensemble de partenaires
historiques de leur rue bien sûr l'USA
Action Logement et la Caisse des Dépôts
mais également l'ADEME pour avoir une
réponse sans couture par rapport au
projet qui sont portés et essayer
d'avoir une vision globale de ces enjeux
et de ne pas traiter uniquement la
partie thermique mais bien d'essayer
d'apporter une réponse globale sur la
rénovation énergétique des logements
sociaux voilà rapidement sur quartier
résilient la façon dont nous travaillons
bien sûr je pourrais répondre à toutes
vos questions plus précises après vous
en aviez de nombreuses mais c'était pour
très rapidement vous présenter là où
nous en sommes
merci beaucoup Madame la Directrice
Générale monsieur le directeur de la
régie immobilière ville de Paris merci
donc pour illustrer ce propos un peu sur
un organisme alors nous en fait nos
sentons cette année et on a un
patrimoine qui a 50 ans de moyenne d'âge
ce qui est pas neutre dans cette
question de rénovation alors comme l'a
dit madame la Présidente nous on est
volontaire pour s'engager on a des 2018
écrit notre stratégie bas carbone pour
savoir comment jusqu'à
2050 on arrivait à respecter la
trajectoire nationale et donc on est
volontaire y compris pour innover on a
testé des solutions d'énergie
renouvelables que peu d'acteurs tests
sur de la récupération du chaleur fatale
de centre de data center ou autre et on
a des partenaires de recherche avec le
CSTB pour essayer de trouver des
nouvelles solutions de décarbonation en
tout cas on est prêt à y contribuer la
difficulté alors on voit comme vous
l'avez dit l'éradication des étiquettes
F et G en 2025 et 2028 c'est pas le plus
gros du sujet le plus gros du sujet
c'est c'est le blog des étiquettes eux
qui est chez nous à peu près 25% du
patrimoine et donc ça représente quand
même des volumes de logement assez
considérable avec une question qui est
que nous en plus on est dans un contexte
urbain contraint avec une des
contraintes patrimoniale à respecter et
donc on voit que la rénovation ne
suffira pas à la décarbonation et donc
on est obligé de changer les vecteurs
énergétiques et là je ne peux qu'abonder
sur les deux questions de coût de
l'énergie où on a plus de tarifs
réglementé quand même faut le savoir ce
qui est quand même une difficulté dans
le contexte actuel et de poids carbone
de l'énergie c'est à dire que nos
locataires ils ont ils peuvent
difficilement accepter le passage à un
réseau de chaleur si il augmente leur
charge de 50% ce qui peut être le cas
dans certaines situations donc pour nous
c'est une vraie difficulté et on voit
que certains réseaux de chaleur alors
des fois c'est pour passer le BBC de
certains financements mais sur certaines
zones d'aménagement les niveaux
d'ambition des aménageurs font qu'on
n'arrive pas à passer avec les réseaux
de chaleur et donc on est obligé de
trouver des solutions alternatives ou de
déroger à l'ambition initiale qu'on
s'était fixé en tout cas cette question
du poids carbone des réseaux de chaleur
et un vrai sujet et puis dans la
stratégie nationale il y a un large
recours à la pompe à chaleur qui est
quand même fortement évoqué ce qui est
quand même un sujet complexe en milieu
urbain et aujourd'hui très peu maîtrisé
par les à la fois les industriels et les
meneurs et donc on a le risque pour
arriver à avoir des résultats très
favorables de mettre des solutions qui
sont pas qui ont pas des niveaux réels
qui atteignent les niveaux théoriques et
donc ça pour nous c'est un vrai sujet
d'avoir quand même des solutions
pérennes durables expérimentées et sur
lesquels on peut s'appuyer parce que
sinon on risque d'avoir des dérives par
rapport aux calculs aux calculs
théoriques
il y a la question qui aime du
patrimoine ancien vous l'avez dit les
patrimoine avant 48 est très pénalisé
sur les étiquettes DPE et donc nous on
est en train de faire notre campagne
parce qu'on a attendu que la
réglementation se stabilise et donc nous
on aura fini à la fin de l'année la
campagne de nouveaux DPE donc par
rapport à la question de la
programmation c'est-à-dire qu'on a dû
commencer à programmer sans connaître
les étiquettes en tout cas en
connaissant les étiquettes précédentes
sur la question du patrimoine ancien
c'est des questions compliquées puisque
comme je disais comme c'est défavorisé
dans le cadre des DPE on a des grandes
difficultés à atteindre les niveaux
objectifs et donc on va avoir des coûts
de travaux qui là vont largement
dépasser et voir on va devoir mettre des
solutions complexes à mettre en oeuvre
notamment l'isolation par l'intérieur
moi je pense aux immeubles en briques
rouges qui font la ceinture parisienne
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sûr d'avoir des
solutions sans faire de l'isolation par
l'intérieur ce qui peut supposer le
relogement temporaire ce qui peut
supposer la perte de surface donc avec
des complexités de mise en oeuvre parce
que des contraintes de relogement dans
un contexte de tension fort des
économiques puisque en plus du coup des
travaux on va avoir une perte de loyer
avec une perte de surface et donc des
vraies difficultés sur ces sur ces
immeubles anciennes si on applique la
méthode telle qu'elle reste telle
qu'elle est actuellement
moi j'abonde à toutes les préconisations
qui sont faites par le SS sur la
question financière pour l'illustrer
nous on avait un résultat au moment où
le livret a été à 1% on avait un
résultat d'à peu près 40 à 50 millions
par an le 1% de livret A c'est une perte
de plus de 15 millions par an donc vous
voyez la
difficulté de trouver de
l'autofinancement pour faire ces
opérations et en parallèle continuent à
se développer puisque quand même notre
vocation c'est de gérer notre parc et
puis de se développer sur la question de
la filière
si on augmente de ce volume là c'est
quand même pas un sujet simple de faire
des travaux en m'y occupés je pense que
tous les auteurs le vivent c'est souvent
des travaux compliqués mal vécus par les
locataires dont les professionnels sont
pas toujours on pas pris en
considération cette dimension là et
l'exigence sociale liée à cette gêne des
travaux et donc je pense qu'il faut
quand même que la totalité de la filière
se professionnalise sur ces travaux
d'autant plus si on fait des travaux de
plus en plus ambitieux si on fait de
l'isolation par l'intérieur plus on va
être invasif plus il va falloir être
exigeant vis-à-vis des professionnels et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a
collectivement à progressé sur le sujet
alors nous on traite effectivement
plutôt les opérations globalement on
fait pas que la thermique avec deux
sujets qui nous préoccupent à la
question du vieillissement de la
population ou à chaque rénovation on
fait de l'adaptation de salle de bain
parce que nous on a je crois quasiment
30 % de notre de nos habitants qu'on
plus de 65 ans et donc dans 10 ans ils
auront plus de 75 ans donc cette
question de prise en compte de
vieillissement de ces rénovations elle
est cruciale pour nous et une question
de plus en plus prégnante que la
question du confort d'été on commence à
avoir quasiment plus de réclamations de
l'été pour des problèmes de surchaleur
que l'hiver pour des problèmes de de
froid donc ça nous pose des questions y
compris quand j'évoque l'isolation par
l'intérieur bah c'est quelque chose qui
est très favorable l'hiver mais qui est
potentiellement presque défavorable
l'été donc on a ces sujets il faut quand
même qu'on arrive à prendre le sujet
dans sa coupe dans sa globalité avec
cette question ou aujourd'hui on parle
du DPE qui ne prend en question que la
question hivernale la question estivale
est sous-estimée et on sait que la
chaleur aujourd'hui c'est pas la chaleur
dans 20 ans et donc pour nous il y a
quand même un sujet de de construire et
de réhabiliter avec des choses qui vont
être durables parce que comme je disais
non à 100 ans et notre patrimoine il a
50 ans et on espère bien que ça dure
ainsi et donc il faut qu'on fasse des
choses qui soient très durables et donc
on a une ambition à faire
ces projets qui sont coûteux puisque
nous on est je pense on était à 50 000 €
en moyenne avant qu'on ait les
inflations donc aujourd'hui c'est notre
moyenne à plutôt 60000 euros et alors on
sait pas quelle est la perspective
durable du marché du Bâtiment c'est nous
c'est un flou art à chaque appel
d'offres on a un peu surpris sur les
prix qui sortent aujourd'hui on a une
difficulté à se projeter et donc en
fonction de ça on a une difficulté à
prévoir notre capacité de rénovation
voilà en tout cas nous on est favorable
à expérimenter à avancer mais avec
toutes ces contraintes qui font que le
sujet est complexe
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur je
vais laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur
[Musique]
dynamique c'est bien plus global je veux
dire quand on a des passoires thermiques
ou des logements indignes
c'est pas que enfin voilà on peut
changer juste la chaudière effectivement
ne plus être carbonée on aura pour
autant pas réglé l'ensemble des
problèmes donc peut-être comment
justement vous arrivez à allier en fait
l'ensemble de ces objectifs quoi à la
fois la carte carbonation vous en avez
parlé sur toutes les problématiques de
réseau de chaleur etc
tout en travaillant aussi sur ce type de
logement ça me permet peut-être de faire
le lien aussi sur comment c'est vrai que
dans le déplacement qu'on a fait à
L'Isle-d'Abeau je croyais que c'était
assez intéressant c'est que l'opération
qui a été réalisée a été aussi en lien
avec ce que faisait la commune sur
l'aménagement de ces espaces ces espaces
urbains notamment sur les îlots de
chaleur etc pour redonner des espaces un
peu plus intéressants des millions à
part de la voiture etc et de savoir
comment allier justement ces opérations
de rénovation thermique et je dirais
d'aménagement urbain plus plus global
et qui sont aussi une réponse d'ailleurs
pour le pour le confort thermique d'été
si on peut travailler sur ces aspects là
et donc voilà c'est ce que vous avez des
difficultés en tout cas de concomitance
avec ce que peuvent faire des des
collectivités et puis vos interventions
peut-être une question sur le sur le DPE
bon vous l'avez aussi abordé on est dans
la deuxième phase et c'est vrai que vous
avez dit que ben voilà t'attendre un
petit peu de sa mise sa mise en place
mais peut-être avoir plus de précisions
sur les enfin à la fois l'efficacité de
ce DPE effectivement de peut-être son
adaptation sur sur des logements anciens
etc où on voit qu'on a déjà quand même
des éléments qui sont qui sont plutôt
plutôt problématiques en tout cas qui
sont pénalisants et peut-être alors vous
êtes moins concernés puisque c'est plus
en copropriété privée mais c'est vrai
que sur la question de d'avoir un DPE
global sur l'ensemble d'une d'un
bâtiment et pas forcément ADPE par
logement qui peut être aussi des
réflexions qui peuvent permettre d'avoir
quelque chose de plus le plus simple
aussi en termes d'intervention et de
globaliser plutôt par bâtiment
une petite question aussi sur c'est vrai
que on a eu on n'a pas encore auditionné
mais on a vu par exemple Esther Duflot
qui pointait la question
en disant en gros pour faire simple que
voilà c'est la rénovation thermique
telle qu'on envisageait d'être très
coûteuse avait peut-être au bout du
compte peu d'efficacité en tout cas il
fallait beaucoup de temps et que c'était
peut-être plus intéressant d'agir plutôt
sur l'individualisation du chauffage sur
les comportements
et donc avoir votre avis là-dessus et
savoir dans vos logements et dans vos
dans vos collectifs en tout cas est-ce
que il y a des exemples est-ce qu'il y a
des possibilités en tout cas d'agir sur
l'individualisation du chauffage et sur
le fait que justement il y a des
comportements on va dire plus vertueux
pour les pour les habitants et la
possibilité d'agir sur le leur type de
chauffage en tout cas de d'arriver à
faire des économies par par l'usage
voilà et puis dernière petite question
sur dans mon lien aussi avec leur rue et
puis et puis sur les opérations que vous
pouvez mener c'était aborder sur
toujours à la questionnement de savoir
est-ce que on fait une rénovation
globale est-ce que on démolit elle fait
ce qu'on fait de la deuxième une
deuxième vie et du coup avec une
intervention très lourde savoir un petit
peu justement comment vous abordez vous
positionnez pour faire prendre en fait
les bonnes décisions et les bons choix
que ce soit à la fois niveau financier
et puis au niveau résultat et puis aussi
de comment vous intégriez le zan puisque
il y a aussi cet objectif de se voir qui
utilisation et donc du coup parfois
aussi cette réflexion de se dire qu'une
une rénovation sur un complexe
immobilier peut être aussi l'occasion
soit de rajouter des logements soit
d'utiliser mieux la surface qui peut
être qui peut être disponible et donc du
coup répondre aussi à cette meilleure
utilisation du du foncier donc voir
aussi comment vous intégrer ces données
là merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour
essayer de tenter de répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions alors j'ai
dit oui le calendrier de toute façon il
est là et on estime qu'il faut il faut
le tenir alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
pris cette position plutôt collective
même si elle est difficile
là je parle en tant qu'Union mais il
faut le dire je vous l'ai dit les
patrimoines sont répartis de manière
bien égale sur le territoire mais les
opérateurs d'HLM sont sensibles au sujet
de manière très inégale si schématise en
Bretagne vous avez très peu de EFG c'est
lié à des patrimoines plus récents et
beaucoup d'électricité dans l'énergie
les opérateurs des Hauts-de-France ou du
Grand Est l'Île-de-France sont beaucoup
plus impactés en plus c'est despe sont
pas les mêmes en fonction des régions et
puis on a un opérateur en maison et cité
qu'à 60 000 logements dans le bassin
mini du Nord et du Pas-de-Calais il est
ultra impacté et donc je vous cache pas
aussi que
si j'ai dit que le calendrier était
réalisable j'ai aussi tout de suite dit
quand la loi est sortie et qu'il fallait
que pour l'ensemble des acteurs je
l'aime on est un principe de solidarité
on l'ensemble des organismes et qui
comprit les moyens ailles vers les
patrimoines les plus énergivores parce
que il faut absolument aider les
bailleurs qui sont les plus impactés et
les bailleurs sont pas fautifs à avoir
du patrimoine aujourd'hui classé Angers
je pense c'est important aussi de le
dire parce que certains nous disent vous
n'avez qu'à faire les travaux on parle
de patrimoine qui avant le nouveau DPE
déjà été pas toujours classé dans ces
niveaux là donc il y a eu de la
dégradation puisqu'en fait on ne prenait
pas en compte le volet carbone donc on
prenait que l'encontre la question de la
consommation donc vous avez des
patrimoines qui étaient en eux c'était
pas un super bon DPE c'était pas non
plus dégradant qui aujourd'hui se
retrouve en Angers et ça c'est la
première chose et puis la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il y a des patrimoine sur
lequel on a des interrogations est-ce
que ce patrimoine a vocation à être
démoli ou est-ce qu'il faut être
qu'est-ce qui doit être vendu
puisque je rappelle aussi que depuis
cinq ans on nous demande de vendre du
patrimoine pour financer l'ensemble des
politiques du logement social et autres
et donc ça aussi posé ces questions là
et puis c'est vrai aussi que sur
certains patrimoine alors notamment les
patrimoine qui sont dans les territoires
qui parisiens mais je pense aussi à Lyon
et en fait dans les patrimoines qui sont
type haussmanniens plus les patrimoine
briques rouges qui sont très
particuliers on est sur des
interrogations qui sont pas nouvelles ça
fait 15 ans qu'on se pose la question de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on doit les
habiliter parce que si on les
rabbilitant juste en laissant capsulant
d'une part on ne peut pas au niveau des
avef mais par ailleurs c'est ça qui va
faire mourir ces bâtiments parce que les
enjeux de respiration et qu'il faut
trouver les matériaux qui vont sur la
réhabilitation ne ces patrimoine en
briques en termes en terre en pierre de
taille et je dis ça parce que ça
explique aussi par exemple qu'on a du
patrimoine haussmannien qui aujourd'hui
la question est pas de savoir si on veut
ou pas les rater c'est comment et à quel
prix
en sachant qu'on n'a pas la réponse
aujourd'hui je pense important que vous
ayez quand même en tête que dans la loi
climat résilience il est écrit qu'un
décret viendra préciser ce qui relève je
j'ai tout le temps exact mais des enjeux
patrimoniaux et notamment ce qui va se
passer en secteur protégé en avables
secteur ABS et tout ce qui est lié au
patrimoine ce décret à ma connaissance
n'existe pas toujours n'est toujours pas
là il n'y a eu qu'une seule réunion sur
le sujet depuis que la loi a eu lieu une
réunion à laquelle nous n'étions pas
convié nous n'avons pas eu le compte
rendu de cette réunion mais nous savons
qu'elle a existé notamment avec le
ministère de la Culture ministère du
Logement et les architectes des ABS mais
ça pose quand même des questions après
je laisserai l'arrivée parce que je
pense que c'est arrivé à quelques
exemples là-dessus mais quand vous ne
savez pas quelle est la solution qui
peut passer au niveau des ABS vous
faites quoi
alors en tant que bailleur privé ou
propriétaire privé vous pouvez avoir une
stratégie nous en tant que bailleur
social on parle de patrimoine qui sont
habitées et moi la question qui
m'interroge après je répond à vos
questions mais la question qui
m'interroge c'est que on va pouvoir
habiter une grande partie du patrimoine
et il y a une partie du patrimoine
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas et moi ce que
je crains c'est qu'on est des quartiers
à deux vis à deux vitesses en fait qui
est que on est des quartiers où
l'habitat social va être réhabilitée
performant dans les classes AB ou C et
donc des ménages qui vont être protégés
quand même plutôt de la dépense
énergétique et donc des charges et du
patrimoine parce que soit il en
patrimoine il est en secteur protégé
classé ou alors du patrimoine en
copropriété ou les copropriétaires
n'auront pas accepté de voter les
travaux où là on ne va rien faire et la
loi prévoit dans ce cas là il peut y
avoir des contentieux mais on peut rien
faire et donc ça voudrait dire que nous
en tant qu'opérateur social on aurait
des patrimoine qui seraient à deux
vitesses par rapport à ça et ça et ça
pose des questions y compris dans la
manière dont on peut maintenir dans de
la pauvreté des locataires qui auraient
des charges beaucoup plus fortes et qui
seraient pas compensées je pense que
c'est important d'avoir ça en tête parce
que dans nos choix stratégiques c'est
aussi d'éviter ça pour dire les choses
franchement et de la même manière que
quand il y a eu l'augmentation des coûts
d'énergie on a tenté au maximum de
protéger nos locataires les plus pauvres
de ces augmentations d'énergie avec les
moyens qu'on a pu on essaie aussi demain
de cibler en priorité très clairement
les quartiers où on sait que les niveaux
de pauvreté seront les plus pauvres
parce que c'est là où on sait que les
travaux doivent intervenir en premier
parce que faire ces travaux c'est quand
même protégé dans l'avenir les
locataires mais aussi le territoire de
ces difficultés est-ce que le calendrier
actuel est réaliste il me semble même si
on connaît les difficultés ce qui
revient sur le parc privé des
difficultés
est-ce que le calendrier du fit for
fifty-five et réaliste ça c'est une
autre chose
et surtout
je dis ça une connaissons pas encore
totalement les les choix qui sont faits
par le gouvernement sur l'application de
ce calendrier là donc de décarbonation
mais ce que je trouve un peu regrettable
actuellement c'est qu'on demande un
effort au parc résidentiel et je dis
bien au parc résidentiel qui est
considérable par rapport aux autres
secteurs émetteurs des gaz à effet de
serre que ça soit l'agriculture les
transports ou le parc de parc tertiaire
et c'est une des difficultés parce que
je vais dire les choses très honnêtement
les propriétaires privés aujourd'hui
occupant de leur logement peuvent ne pas
faire les travaux
les propriétaires qui aujourd'hui lou
peuvent demain décider de ne plus louer
et comme ça ils sortent du sujet de la
rénovation nous bailleurs sociaux vu que
notre mission est de loger des gens et
d'avoir du parc locatif on doit faire
les travaux quoi qu'il arrive parce que
si on les fait pas ça veut dire qu'on
diminue le parc de le parc locatif à
disposition et donc
moi j'ai alerte quand même sur le fait
que parce qu'on sait faire qu'on est
volontaire et qu'on pense qu'il faut le
faire on nous demande des efforts qu'il
a vont être complètement impossibles à
faire on pense et peut-être que dans
cinq ans vous me direz que je me suis
trompé on pense qu'on est capable de
tenir le calendrier 2025 2028 2034 par
contre moi je vais vous dire on n'est
pas capable de l'accélérer
on est capable de le respecter je pense
que ça sera déjà un effort considérable
et et
il me semble vraiment que c'est
important et ça rejoint votre crainte
monsieur le sénateur sur la réflexion
uniquement carbone alors le DPE actuel
il essaie les deux il a lit une question
de consommation une question de vecteur
d'énergie un patrimoine extrêmement
énergivore vous pouvez changer le gaz en
électricité ça reste ultra énergivore et
de toute façon il restera rangée mais
c'est quand même vrai que que le poids
carbone de l'énergie ayant une dans le
calcul global est ancien important c'est
quand même vrai que moi je crains que on
se focalise sur la performance thermique
énergétique et qu'on regarde par le
reste il y a ce que vous dites
l'aménagement dans le quartier
l'enrue nous y a poussé et moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt intelligent mais c'est
très cher et compliqué à mettre des
balcons dans des réhabilitations suite
notamment à la crise covid mais
typiquement ce qu'on est capable de
faire en euros il faut qu'on soit
capable de le faire ailleurs il y a pas
comment eux que les gens ont besoin d'un
espace extérieur ils en ont besoin dans
beaucoup d'endroits et ça nous a fait
beaucoup réfléchir et on essaie de le
faire
et puis il y a ce que vous dites par
ailleurs le confort d'été ça va être ce
qu'on amène dans le logement mais ça va
être aussi est-ce qu'on est capable de
ramener des ombrières de végétaliser de
renaturer c'est ce qu'on fait beaucoup
et là je vous cache pas aujourd'hui que
on le fait notamment dans des
collectivités qui nous ont poussé à
utiliser nos fonciers actuels tels
qu'ils sont pour essayer de renaturer et
c'est très vite efficace c'est très
intéressant on peut faire chuter très
vite à température autour de résidence
de faire chuter facilement de 5 à 10°
avec des de la rénaturation qui nous
permet de répondre un tout petit peu au
confort au confort d'été sur l'usage sur
le DPE je laisserai avant charrier
répondre sur toutes les questions sur le
DPE mais sur la question que vous posez
en effet
est-ce qu'on doit faire ces travaux
est-ce que c'est un pacte pas des
locataires trop pauvres etc il y a
plusieurs choses d'une part les
locataires aujourd'hui quand nous
faisons des travaux de réhabilitation
là je parle de logement dans lequel le
locataire ne bouge pas enfin reste donc
il y a pas de changement de loyer les
loyers d'une part ils sont augmentés ça
la relocation ce qui peut exister c'est
une troisième ligne de quittance je le
rappelle que la troisième ligne de
quittance qui peut être utilisée pour
les locataires enfin pour le finance
enfin pour les travaux de gravitation
c'est pas pour financer les travaux la
troisième ligne de quittance elle vise à
faire partager l'économie sur les
l'économie liée aux économies de
dépenses énergétique à venir à moitié
entre le propriétaire et le locataire
et on va dire les choses franchement on
parle de troisième ligne de quittance
qui peuvent être de 20 30 40 euros par
mois chez certains locataires sur des
programmes qui sont autour de 50 000
euros au logement et la troisième le dis
souvent ça est là pour 15 ans elle ne
cherche pas du tout à financer le
programme on parle souvent d'une somme
qui va représenter sur 15 ans de 1000 ou
3000 euros elle permet de partager
l'économie générée par rapport à la
dépense énergétique plus faible et par
ailleurs elle permet aussi
de rendre plus visible mais c'est une
possibilité que offerte au bailleur qui
est objectivement très contesté et
toujours pas toujours de la meilleure
façon par les associations de locataires
alors pour les bailleurs c'est un moyen
de compléter le financement mais le
financement d'une réhabilitation
d'envergure aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est un prêt c'est des subventions des
collectivités territoriales ou du fédère
quand les bailleurs ils sont éligibles
et je le redis ce n'est pas le cas dans
toutes les régions et c'est un problème
parce que ça crée une distorsion très
forte c'est donc des subventions des
collectivités locales parfois des
fiscalité spécifiques en fonction des
territoires où nous sommes laissés deux
œufs et ça il faut aussi que vous l'ayez
en tête c'est que les C2E dans le cadre
du patrimoine social sont extrêmement
utilisés et représentent une part
importante du financement de ces
opérations et après c'est des fonds
propres et donc les fonds propres c'est
ce que nous avons dans qu'on a généré
des recettes des années précédentes et
qu'on remet et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est un peu nouveau quand vous
faites des réhabilitations qui sont
autour de 100.000 euros au logement vous
pouvez mettre jusqu'à 30 000 euros 40
000 euros de fonds propres c'est
considérable
et c'est fonds propres nous les avons
beaucoup moins et c'est et c'est et
c'est une des raisons qui qui fait que
on s'interroge sur la plutôt la notre
capacité financière à porter ça après
sur les comportements
il est très clair que
les comportements ont un impact sur la
sobriété
l'actualité les demandes du gouvernement
cet hiver sur le plan de sobriété donc
les bailleurs ont répondu présent on
appliqué les consignes de d'un chauffage
à 19 degrés et très clairement on a
diminué beaucoup la consommation
énergétique ça a créé dans certains
endroits des difficultés dans d'autres
moins et très clairement on a vu qu'à
cette occasion mais c'est pareil sur
l'eau c'est pas que il y a l'énergie
avoir des acteurs associatifs qui vont
dans les appartements discuter du poids
des de l'électroménager énergivore de
comment est-ce qu'on chauffe d'avoir des
thermostats etc c'est intéressant sur
l'individualisation des frais de
chauffage qui est un sujet très
particulier pour le logement social
pour vous dire les choses très
franchement le secteur social HLM est
plutôt n'a rien contre l'IFC mais se
pose beaucoup de questions sur
l'application réglementaire pour être
tout à fait honnête avec vous en tant
que ministre j'ai pris les décrets
concernant l'IFC et je les assume
totalement et l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat les a attaqué et a perdu
devant les instances administratives
donc que
je vais vous dire la difficulté dans le
logement social c'est que les locataires
dans le logement social ils choisissent
pas leurs logements ils sont le logement
est attribué il choisissent pas de vivre
au nord ou au sud en haut ou en bas
pignon nord pignon sud il ne choisissent
pas ce qui est très différent par
rapport aux quand vous êtes dans un
marché locatif classique et donc ça crée
aussi avant même de parler de l'usage ça
crée une inéquité très clairement et
nous le savons puisqu'on a fait beaucoup
d'analyses vous avez un même immeuble
bien chauffé vous avez 21 degrés d'un
côté 16 degrés de l'autre
et c'est une réalité donc c'est des
choses quand même qu'il faut qu'il faut
avoir en tête et après c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui il nous semble que le modèle
sur l'IFC tel qu'il est proposé dans le
décret est un peu dépassé par rapport à
la manière dont il pourrait être utilisé
ce que nous montrerait plus intéressant
c'est évidemment de muscler plus
l'action
quotidienne récurrente auprès des
locataires sur l'usage je vous cache pas
que aider les locataires à s'équiper
d'électroménager pas énergivore c'est à
mon avis une des meilleures façons de
faire des économies d'énergie et c'est
par ailleurs peut-être en termes de
maintenance intervenir plus souvent sur
les questions de consommation enfin de
qu'on vérifie plus ce qui se passe dans
nos immeubles ce qu'on a fait d'ailleurs
avec le plan de sobriété à 19 degrés
pour pour avancer là-dessus après l'IFC
enfin les IFC ça rentre quand même et
puis on a le patrimoine individuel qui
est une chose et puis répondre à votre
question sur les histoires de seconde
vie c'est vrai qu'il y a quelques années
je pense qu'il y a des patrimoines qui
ont aujourd'hui connaissent une seconde
vie je pense qu'ils auraient été démoli
parce que on aurait pas su les financer
en fait une seconde vie donc le bailleur
aurait plutôt fait le choix de les
démolir parce que le modèle de la du
financement de la production neuve était
plus simple après la seconde vie à la
vie d'Amand un impact un effet positif
c'est qu'elle aimait moins d'émissions
carbone parce qu'il y a moins de déchets
et de démolition mais c'est aussi
qu'elle sauvegarde un niveau de
constructibilité importante et pour
revenir à votre question aujourd'hui il
y a du patrimoine que je pense qui
passera en seconde vie car il nous évite
de perdre de la constructibilité parce
que
c'est vrai que par le passé on a des
quartiers d'habitat résidentiel social
où on peut se dire si on démolissait on
pourrait réaménager densifier mieux
certaines parties et
disposer autrement les choses mais mon
expérience actuelle me montre que
partout on démolit on perd de la
constructibilité et on le voit bien dans
le cadre de l'enru qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à reconstituer l'offre des Molly
donc c'est vrai que la seconde vie elle
peut permettre de garder
dans des territoires où les bâtiments
sont acceptés en tant que tel et sont
pas considérés comme trop denses de
garder une constructibilité qui permet
de le faire et finalement peut-être de
moins de moins démolir que par le passé
mais aussi un changement évidemment de
culture
Madame la Directrice pour répondre à des
questions du rapporteur qui ont porté
plus particulièrement sur leur rue ou
les quartiers prioritaires merci
beaucoup effectivement quelques quelques
questions sur lesquelles j'aborderai les
éclairages de la rue peut-être un point
pour revenir sur la question des
habitants
pour partager le les éléments de sondage
qu'on avait publié à l'été dernier sur
les habitants des quartiers politiques
de la ville et les sujets notamment de
canicule et et leur réaction face à la
crise sanitaire on voit quand même qu'il
y a un enjeu extrêmement fort lié à la
précarité sociale des habitants de ces
quartiers quand elles se conjugue à la
précarité énergétique dans le sondage
qu'on avait publié en septembre dernier
72% se disait inquiet par rapport à
l'évolution du prix de l'énergie contre
à peu près la moitié quand on prend
France entière donc on voit bien qu'il y
a quand même une prévalence beaucoup
plus forte et la même façon 70% des
habitants récupérés disaient avoir
souffert de la chaleur ce qui revient à
votre question monsieur le rapporteur
contre environ 50 55% sur le reste de la
donc on revient quand même qu'on a un
sujet particulier et c'est pour ça que
nous nous considérons qu'il faut encore
renforcer dans le cadre du programme de
renouvellement urbain la prise en compte
de ces enjeux d'adaptation au changement
climatique de manière globale alors pour
répondre à votre question et sur la
question de l'alliance de l'ensemble des
objectifs c'est bien un des fondements
de la rue de travailler sur un projet
global sur un quartier
c'est ce que nous faisons déjà avec le
NP NRU notamment sur le sujet de
mobilité où nous regardons toujours
avant enfin dans le cas des projets et
de la discussion avec les porteurs de
projets qui vous le savez sont les
intercommunalités en grande majorité
quelques exceptions d'outre-mer mais on
va dire les intercommunalités pour pas
rentrer dans les exceptions et les mères
bien évidemment nous regardons toujours
les desserts en transports en commun et
pour me rendre sur de très nombreux
quartiers partout en France on a de plus
en plus de quartiers qui sont reliés par
le tramway vous le savez madame la
Présidente pour ce qui concerne les
quartiers que vous connaissez très bien
mais dans beaucoup de quartiers que je
peux visiter
nous on a des desserts de plus en plus
fortes en mobilité
en transport en commun et un travail
très fort sur les mobilités douces et
tout l'enjeu de la démarche quartier
résilient que nous avons initié c'est
justement d'essayer d'apporter des
réponses globales qui permettent de
travailler à la fois sur le logement et
sur la performance à la fois thermique
et l'autoproduction d'énergie ou les
modes d'énergie propre pour les
logements mais aussi sur la renaturation
des espaces sur les systèmes de d'aide à
la mobilité et d'avoir vraiment une
approche une approche globale cette
approche globale elle nous semble
essentielle parce que c'est le moyen de
répondre plus globalement certes à la
stratégie nationale bac carbone mais
plus globalement aux enjeux de
l'adaptation au changement climatique et
à son atténuation et dans les quartiers
notamment les quartiers renouvellement
urbains on a un enjeu particulièrement
fort parce que l'artificialisation est
très forte
la densité n'est pas forcément toujours
forte et par rapport aux ânes j'y
reviendrai juste après on voit qu'on a
aussi des potentiels de densification
sur un certain nombre de quartiers alors
qui peuvent être difficiles quand on
démolit une grande tour pour revenir à
ce que disait Emmanuel koas à l'instant
de retrouver le même le même volume de
logement sur le thème en français qu'on
a libéré mais globalement on a quand
même des quartiers qui sont finalement
assez peu dents mais par contre très
artificialisé avec donc un enjeu
extrêmement fort de renaturation et
aussi des quartiers qui vous le savez
sont très souvent les quartiers de
pénuru sont très souvent positionnés
à côté des autoroutes au bord de la voie
de chemin de fer à côté d'un site
naturel problématique et donc avec des
grosses difficultés de santé
environnementales qui peuvent se poser
de ppm etc et donc on essaie de traiter
l'ensemble de ces sujets c'est pour ça
qu'on insiste beaucoup lorsque les
collectivités viennent en comité
d'engagement sur l'approche globale qui
est proposée sur le quartier et donc on
n'est pas du tout là uniquement pour
traiter la question de l'habitat qui est
pourtant central 70% de nos financements
vont vers l'habitat donc c'est bien le
cœur de notre intervention mais à chaque
fois dans le cadre d'un projet global
qui intègre les sujets de mobilité les
sujets de développement économique les
sujets d'équipement public de santé de
scolarité bien sûr de réussite éducative
et si on prend les sujets d'adaptation
changement climatique les enjeux de
renaturation et de rénovation des
logements sur ce point peut-être un mot
parce que j'en ai pas parlé dans mon
intervention luminaire sur ce que j'ai
indiqué sur le fait que l'enrhume a
servi à beaucoup aussi de laboratoires
sur pour tester des solutions par
rapport aux enjeux de ville durable
comme il était dit sur le logement
social on a la chance d'avoir à la fois
des collectivités territoriales et des
bailleurs qui sont présents et qui sont
prévus qu'il y a des financements de la
rue à tester des solutions et qui
peuvent servir aussi de prototypes pour
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions je vous prendrai juste
quelques exemples
sur la question de la réhabilitation du
patrimoine architectural remarquable qui
est un sujet qui se pose dans les
quartiers
particulièrement mais qui peut se poser
aussi dans d'autres sites par exemple
sur les tours nuages des milaliaux que
vous devez connaître à la défense à
financer dans le cadre de son programme
d'innovation délégué du SGPI un travail
de recherche pour voir comment pouvait
réhabiliter thermiquement ces tournages
tout en conservant leurs qualités
patrimoniales et sur ce sujet un travail
a été fait pour permettre avec des
procédés constructifs qui me disaient le
l'inauguration enfin de la première
plaque pardon le constructeur nous a
expliqué que ces procédés constructifs
avec des le long des façades pouvait
être utilisé en centre ancien par
exemple pour faire de la réhabilitation
thermique de patrimoine remarquable mais
dans d'autres dans d'autres sites donc
c'est c'est assez intéressant de la même
façon je le dis assez souvent mais
énergie sprone qui est une technique
d'isolation par l'extérieur vous le
savez extrêmement rapide et qui permet
d'isoler de manière rapide les logements
sociaux simples des cubes des bars voilà
a été testé notamment à Vaulx-en-Velin
donc voilà c'est c'est un sujet
important et je pense que les bailleurs
sociaux sont vraiment facteurs
d'innovation et leur rue les accompagne
dans ce dans ce cadre là parce que ça
permet vraiment de tester des solutions
qui après vont pouvoir se diffuser au
reste du patrimoine autre exemple ce que
je pourrais prendre financer par notre
fond de Pia sur l'autoproduction
d'énergie on a financé ou sur les sujets
de densité dont vous avez parlé on a
financé par exemple des projets de
thalasso thermique pour voir si c'était
possible des sujets bien sûr de
géothermie on a financé un projet qui
était labellisé au dernier congrès de
l'USA à Nantes pour faire en fait un sur
un toit à Nantes un projet d'agriculture
urbaine qui est aussi un projet de serre
qui permet de chauffer l'immeuble bref
ça permet de tester des choses qui vont
pas pouvoir se faire dans tous les
logements sociaux et dans tout le
patrimoine mais qui permettent quand
même de tester des solutions et qui sont
à mon sens extrêmement importantes
toujours dans les éléments de test vous
connaissez nos programmes Cartier
fertile qui a permis de travailler sur
le fait de mettre de l'agriculture
urbaine dans les quartiers là aussi on
répond à la fois à la renaturation mais
aussi à la création de d'une activité
économique en insertion et on travaille
aussi beaucoup sur le réemploi des
matériaux qui un des éléments de réponse
par rapport la déconstruction je vais
venir en conclusion sur quand on fait de
la déconstruction de logements désormais
là aussi l'anglais a évolué dans cette
technique dans le cadre du PNRU on avait
des explosions qui étaient faites avec
une dynamique et avec les logements qui
tombaient voilà et avec de manière assez
assez symbolique c'est plus du tout ce
que l'on fait maintenant on est que dans
de la déconstruction de logements avec
réemploi de matériaux et tous les et
avec des plateformes de tri qui sont
maintenant développés dans beaucoup de
quartiers on peut vous en indiquer si
vous voulez qui sont particulièrement
emblématiques et qui permettent de
réutiliser à la fois par exemple les
baignoires les chaînes etc dans les
logements qui sont réhabiliter mais
aussi tous les matériaux en tri
particulièrement importants donc ça
c'était pour insister sur le fait que il
nous semble et c'est pour ça que il nous
semble important d'avoir ces
financements de de la rue sur ces sur
ces projets qu'on peut tester des dans
le cadre des programmes de
renouvellement urbain pour terminer sur
la question de comment nous choisissons
et comment finalement les porteurs de
projets parce qu'encore une fois l'enrue
finance mais ce sont les porteurs de
projets les collectivités territoires
qui présentent des projets qui les
portent et comment arriver à choisir
entre démolition reconstruction
réhabilitation lourdes réhabilitation
simple et dans le cadre effectivement du
de l'ensemble des contraintes
qui s'impose à nous aujourd'hui par
rapport à la durabilité de de nos
projets et notamment à la fois la
question du zan et de la décarbonation
déjà je vais dire que enfin le fait de
refaire la ville sur la ville le
principe de la rue c'est déjà économiser
du foncier parce qu'en fait on
intervient sur des fonciers qui est déjà
artificialisé et on vient pas en
extension urbaine donc ça c'est quand
même un élément qui est extrêmement
important deuxième élément à chaque fois
on regarde un projet dans son contexte
urbain ce qu'on voit et ce qu'on
constate c'est que les collectivités
viennent plus nous présenter des
restructurations lourdes
désormais mais aussi des démolitions
mais on a quand même plus que dans le
premier programme où on nous présentait
souvent des démolitions et je pense que
la technique aussi de renouvellement
urbain a évolué d'une technique où on
rasait les grands ensembles pour faire
un peu schématique assez facilement et
où maintenant dans une technique plus
ponctuelle de traitement de
dysfonctionnement urbain et c'est la
façon dont on essaye d'analyser les
choses après ce que l'on étudie c'est
toujours une globalité de facteurs on
regarde les dysfonctionnements urbain
parce qu'on a parfois effectivement des
modalités d'implantation des logements
qui sont problématiques et qui
nécessitent d'être traités et qui
peuvent nécessiter des démolitions
regarde aussi la capacité du bâtiment à
être réhabilitée on a des bâtiments sur
lesquels pour les réhabiliter ou enfin
les restructurer de manière lourde il
faudrait mettre 170.000 euros au
logement on a une question elle était
posée tout à l'heure est-ce que c'est
pertinent de mettre 170000 euros au
logement sur un bâtiment ou même en
réhabilitation on sait qu'on atteindra
une étiquette B maximum on n'arrivera
jamais enfin CB et voilà pour atteindre
une étiquette à voir maintenant quand
on a beaucoup de mal donc il y a aussi
donc les dysfonctionnement urbain la
qualité constructive initiale du
bâtiment il y a des bâtiments qui se
prêtent très bien à la restructuration
lourde j'ai des très beaux exemples
certains ont été inaugurés à Rennes par
exemple où là on a enfin désossé mais
c'est 110000 euros logement ils ont
désossé toute la tour ils ont
restructuré c'est très très beau c'est
très qualitatif
et c'est pertinent parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de logements sur cette tour
donc mais il y a des bâtiments qui n'ont
pas ces qualités constructives initiales
et qui ne peuvent pas faire l'objet
d'une restructuration lourde et la
question c'est comment on fait quel
choix faisons-nous par rapport à cette
volonté de recharger les bâtiments sur
40 et 50 ans et c'est souvent ce que je
dis en comité d'engagement lorsque les
porteurs de projets viennent pour
présenter des projets notre objectif
désormais c'est de recharger les
bâtiments pour 40 ou 50 ans on n'est pas
là pour financer des opérations de
réhabilitation à 10 ans et quand on
recharge de bâtiments pour 40 ou 50 ans
on traite tout et par rapport à la
question qui a été évoquée il me semble
vraiment fondamental de pouvoir traiter
tout le sujet énergétique mais aussi le
sujet de sobriété parce que c'est pas
seulement parce qu'on l'électricité elle
n'est pas non plus une épuisable donc je
pense que la question de la sobriété
énergétique elle est fondamentale et
donc traiter le confort thermique qui
permet de traiter quand même une partie
du confort d'été parce que c'est un
sujet majeur qui monte de plus en plus
et les habitants des quartiers
populaires ils partent pas en vacances
ou beaucoup moins qu'avec les autres ils
vont pas à la campagne quand il fait
très chaud donc il faut traiter le
confort thermique et aussi la
renaturation bien sûr des quartiers il
faut traiter le sujet énergétique mais
il faut aussi traiter éventuellement les
restructurations typologies pour faire
face à l'évolution des typologies de
famille on n'a pas les mêmes familles
que on avait dans les années 50-60 on
n'a pas les mêmes besoins en termes de
répartition entre T1 T2 et T6 T7 voilà
on fait plus des tessettes voilà on a
besoin de traiter aussi la
restructuration des pièces de vie les
locataires c'est très intrusif parfois
on fait aussi un site inoccupé les
grosses restructurations dont je vous
parlais elles se font aussi inoccupées
mais quand on est en site occupé les
locataires ne peuvent pas comprendre
qu'on intervienne uniquement pour faire
les installations par l'extérieur sans
faire la rénovation de leur salle de
bain qui est leur quotidien donc on a
besoin de ces restructurations globales
donc ça coûte effectivement assez cher
avec des augmentations de coûts qui sont
liées à ce qui a été dit sur les
éléments d'inflation mais nous sommes
qu'il faut faire cette intervention
globale donc voilà donc par rapport à la
question du choix je pense que il y a
pas de je pense qu'il faut pas avoir de
dogmes mais de normes sur le sujet et
que c'est à chaque fois des choix
contextualisés par rapport aux
situations dans les quartiers mais avant
de mettre 80-90 000 euros au logement il
faut quand même se poser la question de
savoir si le bâtiment
enfin l'ossature initiale la
construction initiale du bâtiment est
suffisamment solide et la deuxième chose
si dans le quartier le fonctionnement
urbain du quartier ce bâtiment à cet
endroit là toujours sa place ou s'il ne
faudrait pas quand même essayer de
retravailler la trame urbaine qui est un
sujet qu'on travaille dans le cadre de
langue après quand on démolit il faut
reconstruire d'où la problématique de
trouver du foncier qui est un sujet sur
lequel on est particulièrement vigilant
mais c'est aussi un enjeu pour nous je
terminerai par là à l'enrude mixité
sociale c'est à dire que si on démolit
des logements sociaux dans les quartiers
c'est aussi pour faire baisser la part
de logements sociaux dans certains
quartiers qui sont à 70 80 % des
logements sociaux et si on veut
renforcer la mixité sociale qui est
quand même l'ADN et le fondement de la
rue il faut aussi pouvoir travailler
soit sur la démolition reconstruction de
logements sociaux en dehors des
quartiers par exemple dans des communes
carencés ou dans des quartiers carencés
mais il faut aussi éventuellement
travailler sur le changement d'usage
mais ce qui nécessite de toute façon le
relogement des personnes mais nous on a
quand même cet enjeu aussi de mixité
sociale qui fait partie des objectifs
qui nous ont été assignés par la
représentation parlementaire qui a voté
la loi pendant le NPN erreur en 2014
sur la question entre décarbonations et
rénovation nous on a plutôt une
conviction que quand même la sobriété
c'est la priorité et donc avant tout on
travaille sur la rénovation la question
de la décarbonation vient dans un second
temps c'est plutôt notre notre
conviction sur la question des usages on
a fait quand même pas mal de campagne
d'écogestes les uns les autres et on
voit que ce qui compte c'est quand même
beaucoup le temps qu'on passe
personnaliser la réponse et la recherche
de solutions et donc c'est là où la
question de la navigation des frais de
chauffage je sais pas si elle répondent
totalement à la question d'autant plus
que derrière il y a une méthode de
calcul assez obscure qui dépendent du
matériel qu'on va installer et qui n'est
pas
facilement perceptible de notre
perception pour pour le locataire et
donc nous on plaide et y compris on
essaie de mobiliser les énergéticiens
sur les comment ils peuvent financer
avec nous des campagnes de réduction
auprès des personnes en plus grandes
précarité pour travailler sur leurs
usages parce qu'il faut passer du temps
avec eux c'est ça qui est le plus
probant avec une deuxième difficulté sur
l'individualisation des frais de
chauffage c'est que nous on a quand même
travaillé avec nos exploitants à les
intéresser à mettre des contrats de
performances et ça ça n'est plus
possible à partir du moment où chacun
peut régler sa température puisque du
coup ils sont plus d'intéressement
possible et donc tout le travail qu'on a
engagé avec ces exploitants et qui
envoie porte ses fruits notamment quand
on l'a fait de manière assez forte avec
dans le contexte de l'hiver dernier et
donc nous on pense qu'il faut quand même
qu'on soit très fort sur vis-à-vis de
nos exploitants pour être bon en termes
de performance vous avez une question
sur le DPE alors nous on les fait au
bâtiment
du coup ça nous évite de visiter chaque
logement mais donc on doit quand même en
visiter quasiment 10% ce qui est pas
simple ce qui est coûteux nous c'est
quasiment 2 millions pour faire une
campagne de DPE et mais après ils sont
quand même redéclinés au logement donc
du coup
on a un bâtiment qui généralement peut
être en eux et puis avoir quelques
logements F ou j'ai ponctuellement dans
les derniers niveaux donc mais en tout
cas je pense que la méthode la plus
répandue chez les bailleurs c'est la
campagne de DPE par bâtiment pour
s'économiser la pénétration dans la
totalité des logements sur la question
du niveau d'intervention enfin moi je
rejoins la remarque sur le fait que ces
personnalisé à chaque patrimoine et
c'est dur d'avoir une réponse homogène
on a fait des une rénovation village
Saint-Paul où on a pu faire de
l'isolation par l'extérieur parce qu'on
a trouvé la moyenne dialogue avec des
architectes avec les ABS et ça marche
après il y a des cas plus compliqués les
HBM on sait pas encore totalement les
meilleures méthodes et puis il y a des
solutions il faudra être plus fort mais
je pense que le mieux c'est quand même à
chaque fois qu'on fait une rénovation de
faire le maximum parce que on nous Inter
sur notre capacité à respecter le
calendrier mais si on doit revenir deux
fois sur une opération à court terme
c'est un faisable pour nous parce que
dans les limites même si c'est pas la
première il y a une question de coup
mais il y a une question des moyens
humains des organismes et leur capacités
de maîtrise d'ouvrage et donc c'est
important qu'on ait des opérations le
plus globale et le plus performantes et
le moins d'opération possible parce que
pour nous c'est coûteux une opération
chaque opération écouteseuse plus que le
niveau d'intervention de chaque
opération donc je pense que pour nous
pour arriver pour avoir une ambition
forte c'est de nous donner la capacité
de faire des rénovations ambitieuses
chaque fois qu'on fait une rénovation je
pense que pour nous c'est assez crucial
dans le niveau global d'atteindre des
objectifs
merci beaucoup alors il y avait nos deux
collègues qui souhaitaient poser une
question
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse madame présidente de l'USH
madame la ministre
je voulais vous aborder avec vous un
point qui est un point un peu un peu
particulier mais qui fait que un certain
nombre de collectivités et de bailleurs
se trouve dans une situation un peu
inextricable hier j'étais dans la
commune de Saint-Benoît de Carmaux
et c'est une une commune qui comporte
60% de logements sociaux
qui pour l'essentiel ont été construits
dans les années 20 donc pour accueillir
les mineurs et cette situation est une
situation qu'on retrouve dans les
communes voisines de Blagnac les deux de
Blagnac de Cagnac-les-Mines pardon de
Blaye les Mines ou de Carmaux même avec
des logements qui sont si vous permettez
l'expression des logements collectif
horizontaux c'est à dire aligné
qui sont pour la plupart en classe F ou
G et avec
des communes qui ont perdu entre un
quart et un tiers de leur population
c'est 15 20 30 dernières années et par
rapport à cela une difficulté pour le
bailleur de remettre alors le curance le
bailleur et 3F qui a repris les actifs
des anciennes filières des houillères et
avec des difficultés pour pour le
bailleur de pouvoir réhabiliter j'allais
dire tous ces logements et faire de
telle sorte qu'ils puissent être passé
de la classe FG assez des comment l'a
dit tout à l'heure
en fait il se trouve dans une situation
inextricable parce que ils ont pas les
moyens de réhabiliter donc et
de rénover tous ces logements mais la
loi en parallèle aussi fait que pour la
session des logements c'est compliqué et
que donc ils vont se retrouver à partir
de
2025 dans une situation où nous pourrons
pas réhabiliter mais pourront pas vendre
non plus
et donc est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
aller vers un cadre de souplesse pour
faire de telle sorte qu'il puisse y
avoir des schémas d'accession sociale à
la propriété donc sur ces territoires
qui sont des territoires alors sous
tendus en matière de logement que ça
soit clair puisque on peut pas faire
quelque chose de généraliser par rapport
à cela mais que sur ces communes qui ont
ces situations spécifiques qu'il puisse
y avoir une facilité qui puisse être
donnée pour se séparer d'une partie du
parc locatif dans le cadre d'une
stratégie d'accession sociale ou des
gens de personnes se feront les travaux
eux-mêmes de de rénovation énergétique
de ces bâtiments peut-être sous le
contrôle et avec des interventions
d'artisans ou d'organismes agréé en la
matière mais qui qui ensuite permettrait
peut-être aussi d'avoir quelques
quelques moyens donc pour ces organismes
de pouvoir réinvestir le produit de
cette vente dans la réhabilitation du
parc existant sur les communes
concernées je crois que c'est peut-être
quelque chose qu'il faudrait pouvoir
pouvoir regarder parce que là on est
dans l'archétype de la situation que
vous avez mise en avant c'est-à-dire que
la mise au norme
énergétique de ces bâtiments dans des
secteurs donc sous tendus où le foncier
relativement bas fait que la valeur de
l'arabbitation coûte presque plus cher
que la valeur intrinsèque du bien qui va
être réhabilitée donc avec toutes les
questions que ceux-ci que ceci pose je
crois que c'est alors certes ça concerne
un tout petit nombre de logements et des
situations très spécifiques dans le
cadre national mais pour lesquelles il y
a quand même un enjeu et et
une attente j'allais dire
particulièrement importante
des collectivités qui voient cette
échéance de 2025 avec beaucoup
d'inquiétudes j'allais dire à certains
égards
alors votre question certes c'est une
partie du patrimoine mais elle est
extrêmement pertinente parce que on
parle d'un patrimoine qui est ancien qui
est loué même s'il peut y avoir du
logement vacant j'ai parlé du du bassin
minier
du Nord du Pas-de-Calais il y a en effet
en fait l'ensemble du patrimoine des
wyers qui peut être évidemment dans le
grand test en Lorraine mais aussi
évidemment dans le sud c'est du
patrimoine qui en plus les loyers sont
extrêmement bas et par ailleurs on est
sur des locataires qui sont vraiment
plutôt dans les ménages qui sont au
niveau du seuil de pauvreté donc votre
question est extrêmement pertinente
parce que il y a plusieurs questions qui
se posent là-dedans premièrement c'est
du patrimoine qui est plutôt du
patrimoine individuel qui a plutôt des
qualités architecturales réelles alors
certaines sont classées d'autres 100
lettres sont quand même partie de ce qui
s'appelle les cités jardin et donc il y
a quand même des enjeux patrimoniaux qui
sont réels on est sur des modes de
chauffage plutôt individuels donc la
difficulté c'est que ce qu'on arrive à
mutualiser dans la réhabilitation d'une
tour typiquement où il y a je vous dis
quatre faces sur 12 étages où on va
peut-être descendre à moins de 40 000
euros 30 000 euros au logement sur un
bâtiment une maison individuelle de
cette période là on va être en
franchement en dessous de 60 000 euros
on fait pas grand chose parce qu'en
effet on ramène de la sobriété on refait
les toitures on refait les planchers on
refait les sous-sols en plus il y a
parfois des endroits c'est des bâtiments
il y a pas de fondation enfin je bon je
rentre pas dans le détail mais et par
ailleurs c'est du patrimoine qui sert à
quelque chose c'est pas du patrimoine
inutile c'est pas du patrimoine qu'on va
acheter comme ça il est habité
où il peut avoir par ailleurs un enjeu
sur la revitalisation de certains
territoires ce du patrimoine qu'on voit
aussi dans les périmètres d'action corps
de ville la question elle est elle est
alors certes ce patrimoine là si les
bailleurs l'avaient identifié dans leur
cul alors convention d'utilité sociale
même s'il en FG il peut être vendu ce
qui est paradoxal mais c'est comme ça
elle peut être vendu aujourd'hui s'il
n'était pas identifié ne peut pas l'être
s'il est FG donc il faut faire des
travaux quoi qu'il arrive pour le vendre
alors je vous cache pas que par ailleurs
je trouve quand même normal qu'on puisse
qu'on doit que le bailleur fasse
quelques travaux pour améliorer la
classe énergétique de ce patrimoine car
je sais pas si c'est vraiment un
magnifique cadeau qu'on fait à des
futurs propriétaires de se retrouver
avec du patrimoine aussi complexe à
réhabiliter mais je pense que ça ne
suffira pas c'est à dire qu'en effet sur
ces patrimoines là et les bailleurs
essaient de les vendre je peux quand
même vous dire que c'est patrimoine là
ne s'achète pas beaucoup par rapport à
d'autres puis alors en ce moment toute
façon l'avantage chez elle mais comme le
reste de la vente de logement au niveau
zéro donc ça pose de difficulté mais
imaginons même demain de faire des
programmes d'accession sociale donc
accompagner sécuriser qui permettrait
d'amener en plus de la mixité de
produits je pense qu'à minima il
faudrait que les bailleurs puissent
construire les programmes de travaux par
classe énergétique gagnée c'est-à-dire
que nous on a y compris nous en tant que
maître d'ouvrage sur du patrimoine qui
est notre patrimoine aujourd'hui qui
demain pourrait être vendu peut-être
qu'il faudrait qu'on soit celui qui fait
les travaux pour le compte du futur
propriétaire individuel je dis ça parce
que ce que je ne voudrais pas et ça
s'est passé par le passé c'est qu'on
vante du patrimoine
que nos propriétaires deviennent des
propriétaires en difficulté et ça arrive
c'est pas une femme ce que je vous
raconte et qu'aujourd'hui des mers nous
demandent et on le fait de racheter du
patrimoine qu'on a vendu à 25 ans parce
que financièrement les travaux n'étaient
pas portés mais dans un plan concerté on
associerait la NA et voyez des crédits
sur la rénovation du parle privé je
pense que ça serait évidemment
intéressant par ailleurs c'est du
patrimoine moi je suis quand même notre
histoire industrielle c'est du
patrimoine qui a une qualité d'habitat
avec un très bonne même si en effet les
salles de bains sont petites c'est pas
très adaptés aux handicap il y a plein
de choses à voir mais quand même les
gens qui vivent ils sont bien ils ont
des petits espaces extérieurs ici
passent des choses intéressantes donc il
faut aussi qu'on trouve les moyens et
c'est en ça que je vous parle de
visibilité parce que si moi aujourd'hui
en 2023 je savais que jusqu'à 2034 allez
2030 je vais juste dire jusqu'à 2030 je
sais que sur les f puis léger puis le
début des oeufs les plus énergivores
j'ai l'accompagnement de l'État qui
prend tel ou telle forme pendant 5 ans
ça me permet en fait de construire ce
que vous dites y compris d'avoir de la
stratégie je réhability je vends un peu
je fais tout ça problème c'est je sais
même pas ce que j'ai dans la loi de
finance de 2024 je dis les choses
franchement aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
s'il y aura une aide de l'État sur la
rénovation du parc social pour le
patrimoine gé en 2024 donc ça rend les
choses extrêmement compliquées
et ce qui est certain c'est qu'en tant
que bailleur social et donc propriétaire
à vocation sociale il me semble quand
même quand on vend le patrimoine on peut
pas oublier l'accompagnement des ménages
qui vont devenir nos propriétaires je
parle pour ce patrimoine ce patrimoine
qui est très particulier mais je pense
qu'on peut construire une histoire
intéressante par ailleurs sur ce
patrimoine là
sur certains de ces patrimoine on peut
faire de la massification on en a peu
parlé là mais quand même c'est tout ce
qui est testé alors tu en as parlé dans
NRJ spring c'est quand même le fait de
massifier les gestes c'est à dire que
pour le même type de patrimoine qui a
les mêmes qualités de bâti de départ
vous fait toujours le même geste avec la
même procédure et on massifie et ça
faire des économies quand même sur le
montage alors des économies pourquoi
c'est pas simplement les matériaux c'est
que ça permet surtout de planifier les
travaux les uns à la suite des autres et
donc de planifier le temps homme passé
sur ces
projets là et vous dire en fin de ce que
je l'ai pas dit tout à l'heure on a peu
parlé des la transparence sur les coûts
des matériaux parce que c'est une
question que vous avez posé sur les qui
explique en fait l'évolution des coûts
de la réhabilitation nous avons obtenu
de la part de Bruno Le Maire la mise en
place un observatoire sur les coûts des
matériaux qui est donc mis en place
depuis de moi j'ai vu il y a quelques
semaines il a redit que pour l'instant
les industriels ne jouaient pas assez le
jeu sur la transparence sur le coup des
matériaux mais ça fait partie aussi de
ces enjeux sur la question des surcos et
très clairement sur des difficultés
aujourd'hui à chiffrer le montant des
travaux
Franck montoget merci madame la
Présidente merci
à vous tous pour la clarté des exposés
et la grande pédagogie
que vous avez que vous avez démontré
voilà et qui vous éclairent sur des
sujets compliqués j'aurais deux petites
questions
vous avez parlé de quartier résilience
et de vérification du respect des enjeux
un moment donné notamment Madame la
Directrice de la rue je voudrais savoir
si vous avez
vous commencez à voir des retours
d'expérience sur l'efficacité des
travaux de rénovation énergétique que
vous avez mené alors non pas dans
l'hypothèse de malfaçon etc mais dans
l'hypothèse où effectivement les travaux
ont été correctement conduits réalisés
avec peut-être voilà une perte
d'efficacité dans le temps de ce qu'il y
a été techniquement réalisé et bien
réalisé
parce que ce sujet si ce n'est un
mais il se rajoute à la complexité de
notre de notre affaire et c'est pareil
voilà donc je voudrais
ma première question et deuxième
question alors fondée sur mon expérience
personnelle de mère dont un quartier à
une époque est rentré à la fois dans la
politique de la ville et et dans le PNRU
c'est à Auch dans le Gers
et j'ai vécu alors ça a été au moment où
je j'ai dû faire un choix
un choix d'élus donc j'ai laissé un peu
tomber l'affaire mais j'ai laissé
derrière moi une situation où
la l'aspect habitabilité
du programme a été complètement éludée
laisser de côté
et je le regrette
et ça me permet de vous de vous poser
une question vous l'avez un petit peu
abordé
il faut prendre plusieurs aspects en
compte à la fois
la rénovation
l'énergie l'habitabilité
et en fait
tout ça renvoie à des objectifs qui sont
pas de même nature mais qui sont
cantonis réfléchit du point de vue des
habitants des occupants tous aussi
importants les uns que les autres voilà
donc par rapport à la situation
d'aujourd'hui où on réfère tout
finalement à la à la dimension
climatique du sujet à l'objectif vous
l'avez rappelé du feed for55 etc
ne faut-il pas
pondérer un peu plus les choses pour
réintroduire effectivement dans les
programmes une prise en compte de la
dimension amitié habitabilité plus
importante que ça n'a le cas aujourd'hui
ou qu'on ne prend les habitudes
aujourd'hui voilà voilà la deuxième
question je sais pas si je la pose
clairement
la directrice générale de la rue
merci beaucoup pour pour ces questions
monsieur sénateur alors quelques
quelques éléments de réponse sur
l'expérience de la rue mais je pense que
l'expérience de l'ISH sera aussi très
précieuse sur ces sur ces sujets sur la
question de l'économie d'énergie dans la
durée un première chose sur le npnue on
n'a pas un retour d'expérience suffisant
pour l'instant parce qu'on a en cours de
déploiement du programme d'un point de
vue opérationnel donc je peux pas vous
dire aujourd'hui si
les bâtiments qui sont construits et qui
sont livrés pour ceux qui sont livrés
enfin qui sont réhabiliter pardon qui
sont livrés
ils respectent à la date de livraison le
label énergétique pour lequel ils ont
été financés après la question votre
question c'est dans la durée est-ce
qu'effectivement les performances
énergétiques sont toujours sont toujours
là pour l'instant sur le NP NRU on n'a
pas le retour d'expérience sur ce sujet
et peut-être que
l'arrivée alors
ça c'est voilà c'est le sujet sur lequel
je pense que ils pourront peut-être
mieux répondre par rapport à votre
question sur le fait de savoir si c'est
monitorer ça fait partie des sujets sur
lesquels avec la présidente du conseil
d'administration de la rue Catherine
votre âne nous souhaitons renforcer
notre intervention sur la question des
plantes gestion qui permettent de suivre
les programmes de renouvellement urbain
et c'est un sujet dont nous n'avons
parlé aussi avec madame la Présidente de
l'USA parce que nous avons parfois la
désagréable sensation quand nous
retournons dans des quartiers traités
dans le cadre du PNRU que le plan de
gestion qui avait été discuté à l'époque
n'a pas forcément été respectée et donc
ça fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
nous souhaitons renforcer d'un point de
vue de suivi la mise le suivi dans le
temps des programmes de renouvellement
urbain et sur la question de PNRU en
tant que tel donc le premier programme
on a une évaluation qui est en cours à
la fois quantitative et qualitative dans
les résultats seront publiés cet automne
qui nous permet justement de voir
comment dans le temps se comporte les
programmes de renouvellement urbain donc
ça c'est plus globalement sur les
programmes et sur la question
énergétique ça fait partie effectivement
des sujets sur lesquels il faut qu'on
puisse renforcer notre travail de
pilotage et de droit de suite on va dire
par rapport aux investissements massifs
qui ont été faits dans les programmes de
renouvellement urbain la deuxième
question sur l'habitabilité
je
dire un cabinet pourrait dire que je
j'en parle souvent parce
qu'effectivement on a notamment on se
rend compte dans les problématiques de
relogement on a souvent des difficultés
dans le cadre du relogement parce que
les les locataires partent de logement
grand
niveau de loyer bas
pour des logements neufs certes mais les
niveaux de loyer qui peut être plus
élevé ça peut être compensé par les
dispositifs domination de loyer de la
rue chacun nous travaillons avec le SH
pour le rendre plus efficace encore mais
souvent des logements plus petits et où
la vitalité est moins bonne parce que
les pièces d'eau sont très grandes les
pièces de vie beaucoup plus petites les
chambres beaucoup plus petites et donc
où il y a des questions de mode de vie
et de confort de vie qui sont plus plus
problématiques et cette question de
l'habitabilité de la qualité c'est des
sujets dont on parle avec notamment le
CNOA les arts c'est des sujets sur
lesquels je pense qu'il faut qu'on
renforce notre travail collectif parce
que nous avons une question sur la aussi
liée au coût de sur la qualité des
logements que nous proposons et de leur
habitabilité et c'est pour ça Emmanuel
référence au sujet des balcons c'est
vrai qu'on a après le confinement
beaucoup insister aussi pour qu'on
puisse travailler sur la mise en place
de des con qui permettent de répondre
aussi au fait d'avoir un espace
extérieur et ça fait partie des sujets
sur lesquels il faut qu'on arrive à
travailler collectivement et la
restructuration de logements de ces
grands logements qui ont été construits
dans les années 60-70 et parfois
effectivement une réponse qui peut être
intéressante ça répond aussi aux enjeux
d'habitabilité mais sur l'habitabilité
au-delà de la question de répartition
des pièces de vie d'autres sujets majeur
est rejoint ce que disait le directeur
de la RDP c'est la question du
vieillissement de la population et qui
est majeur dans les quartiers en
renouvellement urbain enfin dans les qpv
de manière générale parce que la
population a vieilli et la question du
vieillissement de la population de
l'adaptation des quartiers dans leur
ensemble certes logements mais aussi les
espaces extérieurs le fait d'avoir les
services publics pour les personnes
âgées d'avoir les commerces à
disposition au pied des des immeubles ça
fait partie des sujets sur lesquels il
faut que nous travaillons et donc je
pense que au-delà du sujet énergétique
et c'est pour ça qu'on insiste beaucoup
sur le fait que la seule Ré novation
énergétique à notre sens ne suffit pas
il faut vraiment travailler sur la
question de la qualité de l'habitabilité
des logements et je partage complètement
votre votre réflexion dans tous les cas
ça fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
on réfléchit en ce moment à
Madame la prise je peux me permettre une
remarque juste sur ce point de
l'habitabilité
dans mes regrets il y a celui que n'est
pas été pris en compte
une possibilité technique qui est de
créer des baies
je pense que la question du rapport de
l'habitat dans son quartier à la ville
dans son ensemble et quelque chose de
fondamental pour faire politique
c'est à dire pour faire ensemble au sens
politique ça passe par des par des ça
peut passer par des techniques comme ça
qui ont une lumière de rien comme ça
mais qui sont en fait fondamentale et
qui peuvent permettre aussi de gagner en
attractivité
sur des sur des sur des bâtiments ou des
quartiers qui l'ont perdu l'attractivité
je pense que ça peut apparaître comme
des dépenses voilà supplémentaires je
pense que dans le temps ce sont des
dépenses susceptibles de bénéfices
sociales si ce n'est sociétal et donc
politique dans le bon sens voilà je les
regretté pour ma ville donc je me
permets de tout un salon en vous
remerciant vous vous et ce qui vous
accompagne dans les dans les dans
l'action que vous menez voilà c'est pas
une critique pour critique j'essaie
d'être objectif merci monsieur le
sénateur si je peux me permettre votre
question elle est en fait on est
vraiment au coeur du sujet parce que
d'une part je l'avais déjà dit il y a
quelques mois mais réhabilité c'est
rentré dans du sensible on rentre chez
les gens qu'on soit propriétaire ou pas
voilà et puis par ailleurs
à force de nous mettre un objectif qui
est celui de la décarbonation et que je
comprends donc je leur mets pas en cause
mais le locataire si son problème c'est
le cheminement piéton pour aller à son
logement l'ascenseur qui marche pas ou
la boîte aux lettres qui est pas à son
niveau je vais le dire franchement il
s'en moque de savoir si son appartement
va participer à la décarbonation du pays
et c'est aussi pour ça que c'est vrai
que nous on plaide plutôt pour à
l'occasion dès qu'on intervient chez nos
locataires il faut qu'on soit capable de
leur offrir une réhabilitation sur les
enjeux énergétiques évidemment de
sobriété mais aussi qu'on réponde aux
désagréments du moment le bruit alors on
en a peu parlé mais il y a la question
du bruit évidemment qui se pose il y a
la question quand même en effet de
l'adaptation au vieillissement et aux
nouveaux aussi usage de vie on vit un
peu différemment les gens ont des
demandes sur les poussettes sur les
vélos des choses qui n'existaient pas il
y a son année et puis c'est très
important il y a la question de la
qualité de l'habitat et je dois le dire
le rapport qui avait été produit par
l'architecte François Leclerc et Laurent
gérometti directeur de l'éparmanes
allemandes de la ministre wargon il y a
maintenant en deux ans sur la qualité
des logements vous lisez il rappelle
juste des choses assez simples il y a
besoin de logements traversant pour
faire des courants d'air il faut des
cuisines fermées et pas comme cette
nouvelle mode de ne plus faire des
cuisines parce qu'on rogne en fait sur
l'espace mais c'est invivable pour les
familles que les champs soient d'une
surface correcte et que si possible on
puisse ce qui se faisait dans le
logement social jusque dans les années
80 mettre des placards dans la course
dans la fabrication du logement lui-même
pour amener améliorer la vitalité et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nos locataires
HLM qui quittent des logements certes
avec des des problèmes urbains mais qui
sont des logements d'une très grande
habitabilité et la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que nous ne leur offrons pas la
même qualité d'habitabilité sur pas
simplement l'espace mais la manière je
vous le dis simplement d'avoir une
cuisine fermée avec une fenêtre et
d'avoir une salle de bain qui a pas une
climatisation une VMC mais une fenêtre
je dis ça parce que en fait ces
questions là rejoignent la question sur
le confort d'été et demain
l'arabilitation et le rapport il a aussi
rappelé des choses assez simples ce
rapport c'est de retravailler sur la
manière dont les immeubles sont
implantés et ce qu'on joue sur les
courants d'air existant ou pas est-ce
qu'on examine comment comment tout ça
fonctionne et donc de ramener de la
qualité dans l'habitat et je pense que
c'est vrai que nous on essaie de faire
ça à l'occasion de réhabilitations après
moi j'ai souvenir d'un dossier ou des
locataires ont sollicité un bailleur
parce qu'ils voulaient changer les
boîtes aux lettres
ça a démarré comme ça il y a eu trois
mois d'études à la fin ils avaient une
rehab à 50000 euros au logement on ne
changeait ni les boîtes aux lettres ni
l'autre ni le portail rien et c'est pas
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'en fait ça
montre bien que il y a un moment on est
obligé de tenir compte des gens tout
simplement qu'on loge et aussi par
ailleurs des élus locaux et ça on en a
pas non plus parlé mais un peu en creux
avec internalo c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui serait intéressant c'est qu'on soit
capable de mener ces programmes de
réhabilitation plutôt à l'échelle de
quartier pour deux raisons la première
c'est qu'on a des collectivités qui ont
des stratégies aujourd'hui énergétiques
climatiques de renaturation à l'échelle
de leur territoire et parfois les
bailleurs ils sont associés parce qu'on
a été sollicité ou parce que l'organisme
est un office HLM est lié à la
collectivité mais pas toujours et ça
c'est une première chose et puis ensuite
c'est que je pense que c'est dommage
qu'on ne réfléchisse qu'à la question de
l'énergie à l'échelle de nos résidences
dans son appropriétaires alors que par
exemple demain si on équipe par exemple
en énergie renouvelable nos bâtiments
notre énergie elle va pas être consommée
tout le temps mais peut-être que en face
il y a une école de la collectivité qui
elle en journée peut être intéressée et
nous je le dis parce qu'aujourd'hui d'un
point de vue législatif c'est
extrêmement compliqué de réfléchir à
l'échelle du quartier mais je pense que
pour répondre à votre question de tenir
le calendrier et de tenir les
engagements de la décarbonation il
faudrait qu'on puisse en fait lancer des
réflexions à l'échelle des quartiers et
qui permettent en fait à l'occasion
d'une réhabilitation d'un programme
social on puisse faire autre chose alors
on a cette manière de travailler dans la
rue mais ça c'est très lié à des à
s'attaquer mais il y a tout le reste des
autres quartiers d'habitat et je pense
que ça serait une des manières peut-être
d'avancer et
d'avoir une politique intelligente à
partir du moment où il y a des fonds
publics il y a des soutiens financiers
importants il nous semble qu'on peut
faire les choses de manière beaucoup
plus intelligente que juste le bâtiment
dont on est propriétaire
vous avez posé la question de
l'efficacité dans la durée donc nous on
essaie de mesurer les consommations
réelles des bâtiments avant et après
rénovation sachant que on a une
difficulté qui est de comparer le réel
et le théorique notamment avec les dépe
parce qu'on a quand même un écart entre
ce qui est théorique et ce qui est réel
et donc nous sur les rénovations qu'on a
réalisé livrées depuis plus de 3 ans on
a des gains sensibles en économie et
ceux où on est vraiment intervenus
fortement on a facilement 40% d'économie
durable d'énergie et c'est vraiment
mesuré et l'économie réelle pour
par rapport à ça c'est expliqué monsieur
malin tout à l'heure c'est les bailleurs
utilisent beaucoup le contrat de
performance énergétique avec leurs
exploitants alors c'est vrai
principalement sur le patrimoine avec un
chauffage collectif où là on a nos
exploitants ont un engagement de
consommation ils sont intéressés à
respecter cet engagement donc dans la
durée on a des contrats qui sont le 4 à
8 ans sur l'exploitation de chauffage et
la consommation de base qui sert au
contrat et celle qui est normalement
attribué à la qualité du bâtiment donc
ça ça fonctionne assez bien sur le
bâtiment collectif c'est plus compliqué
sur le bâtiment individuel puisque là on
n'a pas d'exploitant qui vient enfin on
a exploitant qui vient entretenir le
matériel alors là aussi c'est une
différence entre le parc social parc
privé le parc social l'ensemble des
équipements sont sous contrats de
maintenance et géré par le bailleur donc
déjà à minima on maintient dans la durée
les qualités intrinsèque des équipements
ce qui va permettre ces éléments là
peut-être une des choses qu'on peut
améliorer pour avoir cette vision là je
rejoint
on a une difficulté entre un une valeur
intrinsèque des bâtiments qui est un
calcul conventionnel théorique avec le
scénarios d'occupation qui est souvent
très différente une occupation
réellement de nos bâtiments de nos
occupants donc il y a cette différence
là je pense qu'on peut améliorer les
choses il faut acheter des choses sur
lesquelles on travaille on a besoin d'un
maximum d'accès aux données par exemple
aujourd'hui la donnée sur du chauffage
collectif on a la donnée puisque on est
le mandataire de l'exploitant et
l'acheteur sur le joint individuel on
n'a pas la donner par logement une
donnée qui est agrégée au logement mais
on a quelques difficultés au plaisir de
ces données et je pense qu'on a besoin
d'améliorer le travail sur l'accès de la
donnée pour qu'on puisse effectivement
suivre dans le temps la consommation de
nos bâtiments et
identifier le bâtiment qui dérive pour
pouvoir intervenir
on va devoir arrêter l'audition parce
qu'on en a une autre qui suit mais
Sabine drakeler nous a rejoint donc et
elle souhaite vous poser encore une
question
alors j'aimerais savoir comment est
appréhender le bâti d'avant 1948 qui a
une valeur patrimoniale ou
architecturale comment sont prises en
compte les spécificités on va dire de ce
type de bâti est-ce que vous estimez
qu'il est actuellement correctement
traité pour pour garantir sa
transmission en bon état
alors il y a plusieurs sujets sur ce
bâtiment là la première des choses c'est
que nous pensons que le DPE actuel qu'il
est prévu et on en a parlé tout à
l'heure il nous semble qu'il faudrait
qu'ils soient qui connaissent
adaptations alors je sais pas si c'est
exactement sur le patrimoine d'avant 45
avant tu pourras corriger mais en tout
cas il y a une partie du bâtiment
notamment haussmannien mais le bâtiment
dont on parlait tout à l'heure le
patrimoine notamment des weasles ou en
fait les DPE enfin la manière dont c'est
calculée ça les défavorise quoi qu'il
arrive et donc ça pose déjà des
questions parce que de fait on demande à
ce patrimoine d'après de gagner des
classes énergétiques avec des questions
extrêmement difficiles la deuxième chose
c'est de et c'est des discussions qu'on
a notamment avec les architectes c'est
que on doit trouver des solutions qui
permettent d'allier la performance des
travaux qui vont avoir lieu quel
matériau on emploie et donc là la
question des écho-matériaux ou de
matériaux nobles va se poser mais je le
dis quand même sur les questions de de
des enjeux sur la brique ou sur ou sur
la pierre va quand même des difficultés
réelles et puis après il y a la question
des classements et y compris
dans certains dans certains périmètres
le sujet n'est pas juste le classement
des façades c'est à dire qu'il comprit
on a des difficultés avec les AVF sur la
rénovation des courrettes intérieures
qui pourtant ne sont pas vus tu peux en
parler et très clairement sur lesquels
de fait on nous dit enfin on nous refuse
en fait l'isolation par l'extérieur et
l'isolation avoir l'intérieur est un peu
compliqué donc aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on manque de technique très
clairement difficile
et par ailleurs il y a des territoires
où en fait on n'est pas toujours en
capacité d'apporter des nouveaux
matériaux parce que c'est pas que c'est
pas admis donc ça c'est un sujet après
il y a des expériences intéressantes
mais ils ont incité que je parlais tout
à l'heure expérimente le béton chanvre
pour réhabiliter par l'intérieur du
patrimoine classé dans le bassin minier
et c'est des résultats très intéressants
alors en même temps avec des contraintes
c'est du patrimoine qui doit vider donc
faut faire des opérations tiroirs vous
déménager le ménage une à deux fois mais
ça permet d'avoir de la qualité parce
qu'en plus on est sur des patrimoines
vous pouvez pas les encapsuler on est
vraiment sur des sujets techniques il
faut que c'est patrimoine respire et
c'est là où très clairement la recherche
l'innovation l'approche des architectes
peut nous être très utile mais néanmoins
je le dis la loi avait prévu que soit
écrit dans un décret des réflexions sur
qu'est-ce qui était patrimoniale comment
ça se faisait aujourd'hui il n'existe
pas donc néanmoins
je veux dire les choses honnêtement pour
les patrimoine aujourd'hui quand on
arrive on sait pas faire et on les met
de côté et je pense que les problèmes
c'est dedans il y a du patrimoine G
c'est du patrimoine occupé donc le
moment ils vont être à la relocation ils
sont classés en descend et même si le
dans un contentieux futur la justice
nous reconnaissait le droit de ne pas
faire de travaux sur ce patrimoine en
raison de ces difficultés patrimoniales
le logement resterait un descend et donc
moi je vous le dis en tant que bailleur
social et c'est donc je reviens à tout
début de mon intervention c'est qu'en
tant que bailleurs social me dire j'ai
du patrimoine qui est classé comme un
dessin et que je ne peux pas le louer
alors je le loue mais sans pouvoir
toucher les loyers il y a quelque chose
qui me pose vraiment problème je pense
que ce sujet sur les enjeux patrimoniaux
il est très important parce qu'en fait
nous on a beaucoup de patrimoine qui
relèvent de ces questions là et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui alors on a des
expérimentations intéressantes on a
aussi beaucoup de blocages et j'ai
l'impression que
personne en tout cas moi je sollicite
des questionnements et je j'attends
toujours qu'on m'y répondre mais
peut-être que
oui après j'y ai pas de réponse uniforme
à nous encore une fois je lui disais on
a fait au village Saint-Paul sur du
patrimoine classé on a réussi à isoler
par l'extérieur et du patrimoine en
brique rouge je sais plus compliqué avec
une difficulté c'est que le même
programme de travaux on arrive à la
faire accepter par certains architectes
des bâtiments de France et pas par
d'autres puisqu'il y a pas de il y a pas
de règles uniforme à la matière donc
donc pour nous c'est aussi on est un peu
soumis un aléa en la matière qui peut
nous poser quelques difficultés mais moi
je rejoins le fait qu'il faut qu'on
travaille collectivement y compris avec
des centres de recherche pour améliorer
les matériaux et les questions de
durabilité on a des questions de qualité
de l'air puisque ces bâtiments qu'on va
isoler fortement derrière on a des
questions où on n'avait pas la
ventilation initiale faut qu'on arrive à
remettre de la ventilation sinon on a
des questions de moisissure et donc avec
des
usages différents où on avait des moins
de densité d'occupation dans ces
immeubles et donc il faut qu'on arrive à
faire des choses intelligentes et ça
suppose que il collectivement de la
matière grise qui soit mise et qui est
pas et il y a pas de réponse uniforme en
tout cas nous on l'a pas vu mais c'est
vrai qu'on a du patrimoine on ne refuse
de l'isolation par l'extérieur dans des
courrettes de 5 mètres carrés
voilà c'est une difficulté quand même
si vraiment merci c'est très intéressant
et c'était vraiment voilà vous avez
donné des des réponses et des
explications plus que complète on
connaît voilà vos compétences et votre
engagement surtout ces sujets on vous
remercie très sincèrement merci à vous
bonne bonne soirée